[Music]
everybody's got to die for this cemetery
is full of people who've died in their
20s 30s 40s and 50s and every one of
them dies of natural causes has died of
a nutritional deficiency disease this is
a blind spot for the medical profession
they don't get a single 30 seconds of
training in nutrition and as a result
90% of the people in this graveyard have
died long before their genetic potential
of 120 and 140 yes health care is
controversial these days maybe because
at some point in our lives we all need
some generally when we feel sick we run
to the family doctor for some pills
quick fix but one doctor is touring
Idaho trying to convince us there's
another way if one look at the
differences between a alternative or
holistic practitioner as opposed to what
you might call a straight during our
thematts practitioner you might use five
or six different things to treat a
patient might use acupuncture nutrition
herbs and each one of these sort of
supplement to each other enhance each
other our dogs get 40 minerals they're
rats get 28 their own kids got 12 or
less it's really a dog's life
it's these minerals it's a secret lasers
grind up these rocks comes out in the
form of glacial milk we're out here
surveying this wheat crop it looks
beautiful but looks are deceiving she
gained 20 years statistically simply by
not going to medical school 70% of the
medical doctors who treat Medicare
patients plunk the exam
[Music]
absolutely not so it leaves you open to
diseases far far more horrible in
arthritis and in fact today I was in
contact with the Oversight Committee
they actually called me from the
National Institutes of Health the only
way that you can get certain minerals
for instance selenium and copper and
zinc is to eat liver three times a week
Monday Wednesday Friday and most
Americans aren't going to do that they
just don't like it everybody in the
studio sticking their tongues out
already
the answer is really not more taxes more
Medicaid and Medicare the answer lies
here with our food
I was like to shout a little bit of a
survey so I know who I'm talking to
how many were here tonight because you
thought this was a tax protest meeting
hey it's an election year it's gonna
happen and then let's see how many of
you grew up in a farm or hey anything do
the livestock sometime in your life okay
great we're gonna get along fine now the
reason why I asked that last question I
grew up on a beef farm myself about 80
miles west of st. Louis like everybody
else that raises livestock you raise a
lot of your own feed to stay in business
economically and we raise corn and
soybeans and hay and we'd grind this
stuff up into a flour and we would add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
we'd make pellets and we'd feed those
calves for about six to nine months then
we'd ship them off to be butchered and
we'd save back the very best ones for
ourselves and you'd butcher them in the
barn now the thing that fascinated me as
a teenager was that we ate out of those
same fields as a family we kept back
five rows of corn we had a garden at the
end of the field where we grow our peas
and beans and squash and tomatoes and
carrots and the part the fast enemy was
I just asked my dad I'd say how come we
go to all that trouble for those calves
we grind up their feed we add vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals make
pellets feed them for six nine months
and we want to live to be a hundred with
no aches and pains we eat out of the
same fields and we don't give ourselves
with same vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals well he used to give me a
lot of Missouri farm wisdom he'd say
things like shut up boy you're getting
farm fresh food fresh air I'll have some
free exercise don't ask complicated
questions so I was glad to get rid of
the farm exercise and go to AG school at
the University of Missouri and they're
my major was in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre but
I didn't get a real answer to my
question until I became a freshman
veterinary student also at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds is simply
because we don't have insurance for them
we don't have BlueCross BlueShield major
medical hospitalization Medicare
Medicaid or
hillarie to watch out for him and if we
were to use a human healthcare type of
system for animals it'd be sticker shock
for everybody your hamburger would cost
you two hundred and seventy five dollars
a pound boneless skinless chicken breast
would be four hundred and fifty dollars
a pound dozen eggs be fifty bucks
so we learned that we could keep the
cost of animal products such as meat and
dairy and poultry and eggs down to where
the average person could afford them
simply by reducing or eliminating the
healthcare cost we do this by preventing
and curing diseases and animals with
nutrition and that whole concept really
fascinated me all through veterinary
school and after graduating vet school I
went to Africa for two years with Marlon
Perkins from the old Mutual of Omaha
Wild Kingdom days and got to play Frank
buck for a couple of years and used the
tranquilizer gun and trompe all over
Central and South Africa and after two
years Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to st. Louis to work on
a big project this was in the early 60s
he'd gotten a seven and a half million
dollar grant to study pollution the
environment ecology and they needed a
wildlife veterinarian on the project and
my job was to do autopsies of animals
that died of natural causes and the big
zoos around the United States
this of course included the st. Louis
Zoo with Perkins directly the Brookfield
Zoo in Chicago the Bronx Zoo New York
the National Zoo in DC the LA zone many
many other big zoos from throughout the
United States and my job was to do
autopsies on animals that died of
natural causes and to look for a species
of animals there was ultra sensitive to
pollution and we're going to use that
animal much like the old coal miners
used to use Canaries remember how that
goes they take a canary and a little
cage down in the mine and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine the canary is being more sensitive
would drop off the perch and die and
give the men a chance to get out before
they suffocated or blew up we were
supposed to set up colonies of these
animals and strategic locations around
the United States and if they became ill
or died from pollution we would know
that there was some impending
environmental doom that we had to deal
with to save the human population that
was back in the 60s now after having
worked on this project for some 12 plus
years I had done 17,500 autopsies on
over 450 four species of animals plus
3,000 human beings for comparison and
what I learned was that every animal and
everything
being who dies of natural causes dies of
a nutritional deficiency disease and I
got all excited about this nutrition
stuff again and wrote 75 scientific
papers for medical journals veterinary
journals international pathology
journals contributed chapters to eight
multi author text books on a subject
wrote one of my own was a thousand pages
as two thousand pictures and I think it
cost 140 bucks each medical students and
veterinary students had to buy them to
pass the course I don't know if they
ever read them but it was one of those
things they had to buy them to pass the
course we sold a few of those books and
even though I had tried to get this
information out in standard research
channels through papers and lectures and
whatnot there's lots of competition so I
really didn't get the interest of the
people who are in power either in
politics or medical research although
things like 20/20 with Hugh Downs in ER
although I did get to go on that program
before Geraldo got his nose broke for
the first time and I was in 1,700
newspapers throughout the world with
that story and UPI and ap but I really
couldn't get anybody interested we had a
lot of competition we just put men on
the moon we had a high-tech cold war
going on with the Soviets we had
declared war on cancer and committed
twenty three billion dollars to finding
cures and vaccines in 1971 so I became
frustrated enough I went back to school
for four years up in Portland Oregon
became a physician and I practiced there
for twelve years as a general family
practitioner and delivered babies and
sewed up chainsaw wounds took care of
hemorrhoids all the things you do as a
general family practitioner but the
thing that gave me the most pleasure was
to use everything I'd learned in
veterinary nutrition on my human
patients and it was no surprise to me it
works just in well in people as it does
in animals now I was always very honest
with my patients I put my veterinary
degree on the wall next to the medical
degree and they'd come in and they'd
spot that and they'd say doc I'm in the
right place I'm here for a physical
looks like you're a vet and I'd say look
I won't give you a rabies shot if you
don't deserve it
and if I saw that they were from the
farm on their intake survey I used to
keep one of these full-length obstetric
loves you know I'd put that on and kind
of wave it in front of their face like I
was gonna examine a mirror or a cow
right and I'd put that on or do a little
AI and their eyes would get as big as
saucers cuz they knew right what that
was and some of them would panic and run
out the door some I was kind of like
basketball defense you know was they'd
never turned their back on me because
they're afraid you know we had a lot of
fun the patients are high and they
taught me a lot of useful things I like
to think I gave them some useful
information we're gonna go over that
tonight and if you take home just 10% of
what I share with you I believe you're
gonna save yourself an enormous amount
of unnecessary misery you're certainly
gonna save yourselves a gob of money and
you're gonna add many many healthful
years to your life if you just take home
10% now there's no extra charge if you
want to take home 50% 100 cent but I'll
sleep well if you take home 10% I always
like to start out by sharing with you
that the human being has the genetic
potential to live healthily to be a
hundred and twenty two hundred and forty
absolutely no doubt about this everybody
in this room has the genetic capability
to live to be 120 240 unfortunately
Americans don't do a very good job when
it comes to longevity our average
lifespan is seventy five point five
about half of what were genetically
capable of and in 1990 when the World
Health Organization examined the top 32
industrialized nations around the world
for a variety of health things a
longevity and so forth we didn't rank
very well we ranked 17th in longevity
amongst the top thirty-two first world
countries that meant that there were
sixteen other countries whose peoples
live longer than we do we ranked 19th
and healthfulness that meant there were
18 other countries whose peoples live
longer than we do before they developed
diabetes and high blood pressure and
heart disease and arthritis and in
cancer we ranked 23rd when it came to
live birth and first year survivability
of babies and we ranked dead last 32nd
out of 32 when it comes to preventing
birth defects what all these statistics
mean is that we have the highest-priced
healthcare system in the world but not
the best and you're a witness to that
if everything was perfect with your
health or the health of your loved ones
if everything was perfect with the
healthcare system you'd be home doing
something else tonight and so just the
fact that you're interested to get
additional information for your health
for the health of a loved one says a lot
is a testimony for what's going on in
the health care system today now
everybody has some little ritual that
they do on a regular basis whether it's
daily or several times a day or several
times a week that they believe will add
healthful years to their life and it
ranges from doing exercise meditation
yoga things like wearing Bergen stocks
there's things like being a vegetarian
juicing ripping the chicken skin off
your chicken taking an aspirin every day
all these various things that we're told
to do and grandma passes down groups of
herbs to you combinations and so on
let's have a look at three or four and
see if there's any proof in the pudding
that there's any real benefit to these
things and let's start out with what is
called the Paleolithic lifestyle this is
where you're supposed to live and eat
like a caveman
now you're supposed to eat everything
raw raw vegetables or all grains you
can't eat any Iowa corn-fed beef you
have to chase down low-fat antelopes
with your Bergen stock feet and choke
them to death with your bare hands
because you know a gun and bow and arrow
are inhumane so let's see if there's any
proof in the pudding that there's any
benefit to that type of lifestyle and
the only real hard evidence we have here
is old Otzi Otzi of course was a
mummified corpse it was found in the hot
spell valley of the italian alps when a
glacier melted and receded farther than
it had anytime in human history and when
they examined this fellow's corpse they
found out that he was in the prime of
life when he died somewhere between 25
and 40 years of age they knew he was
from the Copper Age because all his
tools and weapons on his person were
pure copper net range between four and
six thousand years ago and the part of
this thing that fascinated me was they
did a carbon-dating on his tissues and
narrowed it down that he had died five
thousand three hundred years ago and
they did a series of x-rays on him to
see if he had any of the degenerative
diseases that plague modern man things
like cancer tuberculosis things like
Oh syphilis and so on what they found
out was this he had severe degenerative
arthritis of the circle vertebrae of his
neck lumbar vertebrae of his lower back
into both hips additionally he had
hardening of the arteries
he had coronary artery disease he had
hardening of the arteries arterioles
chlorosis
of the aorta pulmonary artery and of the
iliac arteries going down into both of
his legs and I guarantee you he didn't
eat three eggs for breakfast every
morning certainly didn't eat any Big
Macs he didn't eat any Iowa corn-fed
beef all of the things that are blamed
on these types of degenerative diseases
so there is no proof in the pudding that
the Paleolithic lifestyle has any health
or longevity benefit then there's the
meditation and yoga the body mind spirit
thing that was brought to the United
States during the 60s and 70s by the
flower children the hippies kind of died
out for a while and has been reawakened
in the last couple of years by Deepak
Chopra who's written I don't know at
least five best-selling books on the
subject let's see if there's any proof
in the pudding that meditation in yoga
have any longevity or health benefit
rita guerra age 55 and thought to be the
premier meditation and yoga instructor
in the western hemisphere was the
director of the Himalayan Institute in
Chicago she was a vague and a type of
vegetarian that doesn't eat any animal
products whatsoever and she thought she
was so spiritually elevated she didn't
need to supplement any of her diet with
vitamins and minerals and as a result
she died at age 55 from a simple
deficiency of a trace mineral called
selenium a Cardian map with a heart
attack there's no proof in the pudding
that the body-mind-spirit approached
meditation yoga has any health or
longevity benefit can calm you down
during tax season and finals week but no
health and longevity benefit then
there's this organic food movement which
has been around since Adelle Davis and
people mistakenly believe that
organically grown food is is healthier
for you from the standpoint of nutrition
then is non organically grown food and
organic means has just grown without
sprays no herbicides or pesticides and
certainly it's safer from the standpoint
of cancer but what about everything else
well certainly it doesn't work very well
because it just means there's no sprays
on it says nothing there's no warranty
or guarantee that there's more vitamins
or mineral
in there there was a guy who wrote two
best-selling books on the subject the
secret lifes of plants and the secrets
of the soils name was Chris bird
Christopher bird had known him for 25
years and I used to give him as a
present I would just give him minerals
and things trying to save his life
because he had snow-white hair and we'll
talk about that in a minute
and he just pooh-poohed he says I'm
eating organic grown food I don't need
to take anything else and I was in about
three weeks ago I was in the airport in
Atlanta reading the local newspaper and
guess whose obituary is in there in big
bold letters Christopher Byrd
I wrote the secret lives of plants and
the secrets of the soil sixty-eight
years old he drops dead from a stroke
even though he was eating nothing but
organically grown food so there is no
proof in the pudding that that in of
itself has any health or longevity
benefit then there's the subject of meat
a a lot of people say oh you can't live
to be helpful if you eat a lot of meat
you got to give up meat you have to be a
vegan or a vegetarian of some type or
another and I've listened to that for
years and of course my personal credo is
that a day without a hamburger is like a
day without sunshine so I was happy to
see this I was up in Colorado last week
and they found it in Colorado there's
four hundred people over the age of a
hundred they're 105 and a hundred and
nine and and so forth there's 400 people
over the age of 100 and the only common
thread they're different races and
different religions and have different
dietary lifestyle but the only common
thread between all these 400 people who
are over age 100 they're heavy meat
eaters they're heavy meat eaters is the
only common thread so yes for us meteors
then there's say you guys it was worth
you're coming here at night wasn't it
then there's a salt thing you know
everybody home you got to give up salt
because it causes high blood pressure if
you have high blood pressure you got to
give up salt what's the first thing a
good farmer puts out for his livestock
is about that big as a salt block right
and of course I refuse to believe that
my patients are dumber than an old cow
and so I used to tell them hey just go
ahead and take all the salt you want and
people would shrink and tear and say
Wallach you're you're flying in the face
of all the weight of medical evidence
you're gonna kill people telling them to
salt their food and of course there
never is there never was there never
will be any weight of medical evidence
that said salt is bad for you it
certainly does not cause high blood
pressure this came out just a couple of
days ago May 22nd
Wednesday May 22nd just about a week ago
now and there was a study that was done
it came out in JAMA the Journal of the
American Medical Association the most
pressed digis medical journal in the
world they looked at 56 studies that
have been done around the world on salt
and high blood pressure and they
combined him into one study and some
doctors from Toronto Medical School up
of the University of Toronto researched
all this and they said hey people who
have normal blood pressure there's no
benefit to restricting your salt intake
it does not protect you from high blood
pressure if you have high blood pressure
only 5% of the people with high blood
pressure get any benefit from
restricting salt only 5% and then they
only reduce their blood pressure by
three point seven millimeters of mercury
if your blood pressure is up 25 30 40
points it's kind of stupid to give up
salt for other reasons because it has
nothing to do positively for your health
what he did say over here was that
there's so many doctors that have a
vested interest in getting people off
the salt that they told him to get off
of salt you have to keep coming in and
getting medicine and water pills and
there's that any other why would they
tell you to go ahead and salt your food
and stay home and enjoy yourself you
know and so there is no proof in the
pudding that getting salt out of your
diet has any health or longevity benefit
one more then we'll get into the
longevity thing this last one is the
subject of the Mediterranean diet this
is the one that the medical profession
has jumped on they say the Mediterranean
diet is the answer for the health and
longevity and optimal health and what
they want you to do is give up red meat
and eat lots of chicken and poultry
and lots of fruit and vegetables a
little wine was okay according to the
Mediterranean diet but there is no proof
in the pudding that it has any health or
longevity benefit because the Greeks and
the Italians who eat the most of it
lived to be seventy five point five just
like us here's a hard example Pope John
Paul the second of course is the Pope of
all the Catholics and big Catholic
population in Italy and you'd like to
think that if anybody in Italy was
getting the very best that the
Mediterranean diet would have to offer
it'd be the Pope he's 76 years old just
turned seventy six years old two years
ago had his hips replaced because of you
generative arthritis and osteoporosis
he has failing health he has to cancel
half of his speaking engagements and
half of his administrative duties he's
just simply does not have enough
strength to do that anymore
in 76 is about half of what we're
genetically capable of when it comes to
longevity so unless he's been sneaking
in pull a sausage under the table for
the last 17 years since he's been in
Rome there is no proof in the pudding
that the Mediterranean diet has any
health or longevity benefit let's have a
look at it just how old you can live to
be if you do everything right is it
worth going to a little effort I believe
it is and I'm going to prove it to you
Christian Mortensen here in August of
1995 about what almost nine months ago
now turned 113 plays golf once a week
looks like he's about 85 years old looks
pretty good for a hundred and thirteen
then this gal here d'Oro Ram of Thebe
from South Africa turned 114 in July of
1995 and when the media and the press
ran to her and said Dora what do you
attribute your health and longevity to
she did not say I owe it all to my HMO
she did not say hey I never failed to
take that invitation and go in for my
annual physical what she said was this a
locust every day you know grasshoppers
pumpkin seeds tortoise meat not a
vegetarian wild herbs dried fruit and
starts each day with a cup of coffee so
we're beginning to connect the dots and
put together what it takes to live to be
over 100 don't rush to the bait store
because crickets won't work it has to be
grasshoppers this gal here Jeanne
Calment from France in February February
21st 1995 turned 120 and was documented
by the Guinness World Book records as
being the oldest living woman in the
world and she rode her bike until she
was a hundred and five years of age and
volunteered as a librarian in the Paris
library and then a year later February
21st 1996 just a couple months ago she
turned 121 as she's still documented as
the oldest living woman in the world by
the Guinness World Book of Records this
fellow here from a little town outside
of bogota colombia 'he's name was friend
is he still alive francisco burrows
nuevo chopped arena when he was asked by
reporters what did he attributed his
health and longevity - he said that he
drinks a gallon of goat's milk every day
and the part that fascinated me about
his birthday story is that 40 years ago
his doctors told him he only had a
couple of months to live and his sons
built him a coffin and every morning for
40 years he's been waking up sitting by
that coffin waiting to die nighttime
comes he goes to bed wakes up sits by
the coffin waiting to die he's been
doing that every morning for 40 years
goes doctor told him he was gonna die in
a couple of months probably didn't have
a calendar yes and of course all the
doctors who told him that 40 years ago
or long since dead
in addition to turning a hundred and
twelve twenty five and still going
strong he was still fathering children
at age 90 so there's hope for some of
you guys going to sleep in the back of
the room already this gal here mazuma
dusty from iran according to the Iranian
news agency this was in the Rocky
Mountain news from Denver a little over
about a year and a half ago now January
1995 she died at age 161 and the
interesting thing about her obituaries
to me is that she was survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
to 128 they had never even left home to
go to college yet and her oldest son
Gollum said his mother had never visited
a doctor or taken any chemical
medications or drugs or pharmaceuticals
did take a few herbs during her life so
again we're beginning to collect more
information of what it takes to live to
be over 100 now let's look at a a fellow
from the United States who is a favorite
son of course I believe especially for
people who are interested in alternative
health Linus Pauling Linus Pauling was
famous for a variety of reasons number
one he is one of two people to ever get
two unshared Nobel Prizes certainly one
of the geniuses of our century maybe of
all time he was also famous for his
interest in vitamin C and he was trained
in classical biochemistry and nutrition
and medical schools and and universities
and so he believed you could get all of
your vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals amino acids and fatty acids
from eating your four food groups but he
also believed that you needed to take
extra vitamin C because of the pollution
their air water and food and because of
all the stresses of modern day life and
so he personally took 10,000 milligrams
of vitamin C every day for 35 years
never missed a lick 10,000 milligrams of
vitamin C every day for 35 years and he
still died seven years short of the
magic number of a hundred died at age 93
and he died of widely disseminated
prostate cancer
well after reading all of his materials
and scientific articles in nutritional
journals and physiology journals and so
on and an additional 400 articles by
various authors on
vitamin C here's what I can guarantee
you if you faithfully take 10,000
milligrams of vitamin C every day for 35
years like linus pauling did and you're
a woman i will guarantee you that you
will never get prostate cancer as the
only guarantee i can make about vitamin
c there's absolutely no doubt that the
human being can live to be 120 to 140
people do it all the time
laughter spending many many years
perhaps 30 years looking and reading and
studying on health and longevity in both
veterinary journals and human medical
journals here's what I can tell you that
no matter how you look at health and
longevity there's really only two basic
concepts that you have to be concerned
with concept number one I refer to as
avoid stepping on the landmines this is
where you don't want to throw away your
life wastefully you don't want to smoke
you don't want to abuse alcohol
certainly don't do drugs don't jog down
the highway at two o'clock in the
morning wearing an all-black ninja suit
you're gonna get hit by truck mirror
right you don't want to jump out of a
hot air balloon from two hundred and
fifty foot up with a 300 foot bungee
cord the math doesn't work out then
there's a lot of crazy things people do
certainly lastly I would say you want to
avoid going to a medical doctor because
given half a chance they will kill you
now as flippant as this might sound to
some of you and I know there may be some
health professionals in here tonight and
I applaud you for being here if you are
this happens to be from April 14 1996
the sunday supplement magazine Parade
magazine many newspapers around America
and they did a whole special issue on
when doctors are the problem I've been
talking about this for 25 years and so
this is their kind of what 25 years late
but better late than never in this case
in in April excuse me in January January
13th of 1993 January 13th 1993 Ralph
Nader came out the results of a
three-year study on hospitals and deaths
and infections and injuries that
occurred in those hospitals 1,500 pages
and there's all kinds of things that he
said but I'm gonna give you one of the
bottom lines which just was a shocker to
me said quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote
300,000 to appreciate how big a figure
that is remember he used the word killed
that means that somebody did something
to them to dispatch them they didn't
just die accidentally they were killed
during a Ralph Nader not me let's
compare that with ten years of military
operations in Vietnam and over that ten
years we had lost 56,000 military
personnel for an average of five
thousand six hundred a year and for
these military losses millions of people
poured out in the streets and protested
we had political hierarchy the last
three years of that ten-year war now we
chased a president out of the presidency
and God forgive us we shot and killed
American students in Kent State Ohio
demonstrating against that war this was
for 5,600 military personnel a year now
comes Ralph Nader and says here's one
profession or one trade who kills
300,000 Americans a year through
negligence and you can't even find a
crazy street preacher out here in any
Konnor protest in it well who is it that
they kill is it just a homeless they go
under the bridges and you know things
like that and get the homeless and take
them to the teaching hospitals take them
down in the basements and practice on
them it's not that simple of course is a
little more complicated well let's see
we got 600 or plus people in here
tonight how many of you remember
Betsy layman anybody remember the name
Leeman okay not a single soul I'm gonna
remind you who Betsy layman was just
about a year ago April of 1995
Betsy layman who was the Pulitzer
prize-winning medical reporter from the
Boston Globe the second largest
newspaper in America 39 years old
developed breast cancer and she sat down
by her computer and scientifically
examined all the cancer treatment
centers in the world not just her own
hometown and she looked at the
successful ones and who had terrible
safety records and who was on the
cutting edge of research for breast
cancer and she chose the Dana Farber
Cancer Institute in Boston has her
cancer treatment center and she went in
for her first and what turns out to be
her last chemotherapy treatment they
killed her with a 16 x overdose they
gave her a 4-day dose every day for four
days and they killed her now because she
was famous she was written up in Time
magazine and in every newspaper in
America because again she was a Pulitzer
Prize winning medical reporter for the
Boston Globe but remember there was
still 200 99999 Americans killed in 1995
by the medical profession according to
Ralph Nader she was just one that was
highlighted now this one here I'm gonna
share this last one with you and I want
to absolve everybody involved with this
presentation tonight including the Civic
Center and yourselves and any company
involved and so forth this is my own
personal thing and if anybody gets
arrested sued or assassinated it will be
me so you're absolved of any of this
danger you recognize this gal here as a
photograph a little fuzzy because I
lifted it out of a magazine and the
reason why I like this photograph of
Jackie Kennedy is that it was taken him
her three days before she entered the
hospital in New York for her first and
what turned out to be her last
chemotherapy treatment for cancer she
was taking a stroll in this picture in
Central Park in New York and a brisk day
with a friend and she was diagnosed six
months before her death is having
non-hodgkins lymphoma which is a type of
cancer that normally takes 10 12 15
years to kill you it's relatively
painless say in comparison to pancreatic
cancer which can kill you in 3 to 6
months and be excruciatingly painful and
when she went in for her first
chemotherapy tree
there was no death watch on her because
there was no anticipation she was gonna
die after all she had 10 12 15 years
left to go goes in on Friday night
Tuesday she's dead you're supposed to
believe that Jackie Kennedy died of
cancer well as a pathologist in the
clinician I'll guarantee as sure as God
made little green apples Jackie Kennedy
did not die of cancer she died an
overdose of chemotherapy just like Betsy
layman and if they can kill a Jackie
Kennedy and they can kill a Betsy layman
and not a single thing happen to any of
those doctors they weren't sued they
weren't dismissed their licenses weren't
suspended nothing happened to those
clinics or hospitals what chance is the
average person on the street have not
very much
now here's another survey that Ralph
Nader did in July of 1994 and this one
he looked at the relationship between
doctors medical doctors and seniors
people are age 65 this happens to be
from the front page of the USA Today I
just like the color pictures it was in
every newspaper in America and what this
study said was this 70% of the doctors
who treat Medicare patients flunked the
exam and how to prescribe to the elderly
safely and effectively 70% flunked the
exam and what would happen to American
Airlines if 70% of their pilot's flunked
the exam on how to fly what would happen
to American Airlines if they killed
300,000 passengers a year you see all
this big hoo-ha going on over the
valujet where they killed 109 people
right now the reason why this difference
is this when a jet goes down and
splatters parts of people's bodies you
know say 200 passengers over a hillside
or a swamp it's pretty hard to hide and
so you know it's a kind of a gruesome
thing but in the medical profession it's
more subtle than that obviously if
doctors were to line up cancer patients
and and AIDS patients and people with
diabetes along the wall and mow em down
machine gun to save money for treatment
then people would protest because that's
very blatant but here's one of the many
examples that Ralph Nader gave as to why
this is missed because if people are
busy with their lives you have kids and
grandkids you have jobs and and things
to do and so you're not going to sit
there and kind of keep an eye on things
you assume that somebody else is doing
it
well here's what Ralph Nader said 32,000
hip fractures each year in America are
attributed to prescriptions or
prescribing by medical doctors that
leaves the elderly today
balance and they fall over and fractured
hip trying to avoid stepping on the kid
or getting out of the tub get another
car and this is a death sentence for
29,000 of these people remember 75% over
the age of 65 don't live 90 days they
died of complications pneumonia stroke
and pulmonary embolism and others and I
believe the doctor should be held
responsible for this just the way that
bartenders are armed and they let people
drink too much and drive home and kill
somebody else or themselves and there's
manslaughter and second-degree murder
and wrongful death however you know
whatever applies to that case and there
is an organization called MADD Mothers
Against Drunk drivers because there's
15,000 Americans every year killed by
drunk drivers any members of Mad in this
audience tonight ma dee dee any members
yeah there's a couple any rate I believe
they should redirect their energies
towards physicians because physicians
according to Ralph Nader killed 300,000
Americans a year and they don't even
have to change their towels or their
letterhead they could keep their
initials mad just change their name to
Mothers Against dumb doctors
yes thank you
yeah a couple of more in concept number
one I think you'll have the idea one of
my favorite surveys that was done by
Harvard Medical School was published in
1972 and what they did was look at the
the drug use both the illegal street
drug use and the illegal use of
prescription drugs by medical doctors on
themselves on a weekly basis what they
found out was pretty shocking they found
out the 52% of licensed medical doctors
in America use psychotropic drugs on
themselves each and every week this
included cocaine marijuana speed
barbiturates opium derivatives and
things like fentanyl so what that means
is if you choose to go to a doctor for
every little thing when you leave here
tonight don't be too excited about their
degrees and certificates and and
licenses hanging on the wall what you
want to do is very carefully look at the
pupils of their eyes and see if they're
gorked out on something before you let
them examine you or prescribe to you or
do any kind of procedure even scarier to
me is that 78% of the medical students
in America use psychotropic drugs on
themselves illegally each week and down
deep in your heart do you really believe
that when they graduate school and go
out and practice do they quit using
drugs no they can get the good stuff now
because they're making money right
here's an example have thousands of
these but here's an example dr. Michael
a pot ler 30 years old just about three
years out of his residency we knew he
was a kind of doctor who's going to be
in trouble because he's wearing
Birkenstocks right
now he killed himself an overdose of
drugs and you know he gave himself an
intravenous injection a recreational
thing and killed himself because he was
a medical doctor they eulogized him on
the front page of the San Diego
newspaper he saved the lives of children
but lost his own and in the article said
he devoted his whole life to caring for
children
now unless he was a babysitter a
pedophile most of his life that had to
be a lie because he was only out of his
residency for three years additionally
he was a thief because of drugs he
killed himself with he stole out of the
hospital pharmacy
he was additionally malignant dumb
because after 14 years of medical school
he still couldn't read the syringe right
and killed himself an overdose I mean
these kids who drop out of high school
and can't even read write and do math
live in cardboard boxes they do drugs
every year forever and ever and ever and
don't kill themselves this is from the
editorial page of the Washington Post
Washington DC November 2nd 1992 lining
Doc's pockets if you go to a doctor your
doctor you want him to think of you as a
patient not a cash cow but two studies
in this month's New England Journal of
Medicine shows that doctors are out to
milk you dry and if you're from a farm
you know what that means what a cash cow
is ten months later and The Reader's
Digest very interesting article
September 1993 and to me the Reader's
Digest is the sweetest little magazine
that ever was never never says anything
negative about anyone or any individual
or any group and so I was really
surprised to see this and on page 77 it
says can you trust your doctor and it
lists 12 ways of doctors routinely scam
patients I'll give you the worst one you
can go look up the other 11 September
1993 the worst one according to Reader's
Digest not me the average doctor in
America gets 421 dollars in kickbacks
every time we refer somebody in for a
cat scan or an MRI you thought doctor
loved you when he said you know we've
been fighting that bursitis in that
shoulder for five years and giving you
heroic injections of cortisone in there
and it's just getting worse let's you
know you've got good insurance and
you've got good Medicare supplements not
going to cost you anything
let's run you in and see if they
bursitis is really arthritis to chain
421 bucks now according to Reader's
Digest not Joel Wallach the average
doctor in America gets two hundred and
twenty six thousand six hundred and
eighty one dollars a year almost a
quarter of a million dollars in can't
scan kickbacks
you wonder why health care costs keep
spiraling upwards now the best way to
keep track of doctors and keep a
scorecard on them is to look at the
obituaries in your town and it's not
gruesome but you should look in there if
everybody is dying in their 50s that
should give you some concern everybody
should be dying their 80s and 90s and
hundreds of everybody is dying of kidney
disease you don't want to go to the
urologist in your town so you know just
kind of take a glance through the
obituaries and see if there's any kind
of picture that's developing here about
a year and a half ago this obituaries
and iego newspaper and is it's a
national level tragedy obituaries grace
massara age forty eight died of widely
disseminated breast cancer horrible
thing it used to be a disease of older
women today it's a disease of teenage
girls it's one of those things that's
gotten worse over the years and there's
a variety of reasons for this but
certainly chemotherapy and radiation has
not solved the problem but I read this
little headline here given radiation is
a baby I want to know what that had to
do with their obituaries
so I read ER ran said when she was
six months of age her pediatrician
shrank her a thymus gland with radiation
from an x-ray machine because he didn't
know what else to do she was kind of a
sickly kid and they you know they took
out her tonsils or adenoids and as well
there's nothing else to do let's just
shrink her thyroid excuse me her thymus
gland so what a terrible thing to do who
on earth would do such a thing everybody
knows your thymus gland is there to
activate your killer T cells and
protects you from viruses and cancer and
that sort of thing nobody in the right
mind would do such a thing so I went
into the medical literature between 1945
and 1950 and looked at all the pediatric
medical journals and sure enough it was
common practice back then because the
Army and Navy and had given all the
medical doctors America free x-ray
machines when they closed down all these
field hospitals in this and the other
and they gave these mobile x-ray
machines all the doctors hey go out and
try them doc you know you're a doctor
and there was common practice and
according to the US Department
1 million American babies under the age
of one year had their thymus glands
shrunk between 1945 and 1951 million not
a single foreign enemy has ever radiated
in America neither civilian or military
and the one profession who says well
trust me my dear radiated 1 million
American babies now according to the
American or the US Department of Energy
these kids have either already died of
cancer they're currently under treatment
for cancer or they project they're going
to die of cancer based on the amount of
radiation they received to their neck
and chest to shrink their thymus glands
now you wonder what the pupils look like
on the eyes of this surgeon up in Grand
Rapids Michigan about a year ago when he
took off the normal breasts left the
cancers one on no sober surgeon can make
that mistake I mean even if he was
dyslexic he couldn't make that mistake
because if he's dyslexic the surgical
nurses know that and they'll take a red
wax pencil and put a bull's eye on the
correct breast and put a red ribbon on
the guy's wrist and say doc just matched
the colors even a dyslexic can match
color so you know this guy had to be
gorked down on something and the poster
child as it turns out four Americans
have been injured and killed in American
hospitals turns out to be a name of a
guy by the name of Willie King Willie
King went into the university a
community hospital in Tampa Florida to
get his right leg amputated he had
uncontrolled diabetes he had gangrene in
that leg the bones were sticking out of
his toes as skin was slipping off and
his flesh smelled like rotten meat and a
garbage can on a hot July night and the
surgeons promptly cut off his normal
left leg it turned out okay for Willie
because they cut off his other leg for
free
kind of balance team up a little bit a
couple more I think you'll have the
picture dr. Raymond Sattler a
neurosurgeon from North Carolina got his
license suspended for 30 days according
to this article because he left the
surgical room after he had exposed the
patients brain to the air he left the
patient's brain exposed for 25 minutes
and will dry it out a little bit and
while he ran out and got some lunch now
I don't believe that was the case
because I've done a lot of surgery and
when you get to the point where you're
kind of dancing around you know when you
have to go to the bathroom or you're
hungry it's not the sort of thing that
you're gonna leave a patient what you do
is you go faster you put the stitches
farther apart you put a fewer in but you
get it done before you leave and I
believe that this fellow is one of those
52% of the medical doctors who do drugs
every week and he had to run into the
bathroom and snort some cocaine or give
himself an injection to calm himself
down I based this opinion on remarks and
statements from the Medical Board of
North Carolina and they said dr. Raymond
Sandler forgot the names of surgical
instruments during the operation and
told us nurse to drill holes in the
patient's head with a black & decker
drill him is like Sears home repairs oh
and she didn't know what she was doing
she injures a patient so he got his
license suspended for 30 days his fellow
here is a chess surgeon in Fort Worth
Texas
he was on the staff the osteopathic
medical center of Texas and took out the
normal right lung and left the cancerous
left lung in I guarantee you he
immediately knew that because whenever
you remove something that has cancer in
it you always take your scalpel and you
cut through it several times
take a representative sample put in some
preservative and send it to the lab so
they can tell you exactly what's going
on there so you know how to pursue
treatment this guy knew immediately and
of course it didn't tell anybody says
well nobody will know well it just so
happens that this patient went in for
autopsy after he died and the
pathologist said wait a minute the
results here at the autopsy don't jive
with a surgical record and so just to
kind of keep things quiet the surgeon
settled for nine million dollars with
the family never going to a jury and why
would he do that why wouldn't he spend
$250,000 worth of
of legal fees when the his malpractice
insurance would pay for that
we'd pay for those legal fees and get it
down to five million or four million or
two million he didn't do that well the
reason is I guarantee you he couldn't
find another physician or a nurse who
would testify that he was sober during a
procedure and if that would have gone
before a jury the award to the family
would have been a hundred million so he
was lucky and glad to get off with a
nine million dollar settlement now one
of the things that I think should be
standard and taught in medical schools
is what a dead patient looks like what a
live patient looks like that should be
standard death 101 life 101 those should
be standard courses but you're never
quite sure that they have this kind of
information when you see stuff like this
this gal here
Mildred C Clark 86 years old was found
cold stiff and blue in a nursing home
apartment floor and the house doctor
came in and couldn't find a pulse in
respiration he said why she's dead she's
86 years old let's not go to any heroic
efforts here and run the bills up for
the family and make her miserable in the
last few moments of her life so I threw
her body in the meat wagon and send her
off to a Morgan a little hospital in
Albany New York but the house doctor is
not gonna let you put a body in the
morgue without a death certificate so he
comes down examines her again couldn't
find a pulse respiration declares are
dead rights a death certificate turns
her body over to the morgue technician
who promptly strips her body down hoses
her down with water to clean her up puts
her in a body bag named wheels her into
a freezer for 90 minutes until the
pathologist gets there to do the autopsy
an hour and a half in the freezer the
pathologist and coroner show up so
wheels the body out of the freezer zips
open the body bag and she sits up says
thank God you found me
it was cold dark in there and I didn't
know where I was now she had to be a
tough old bird
if you don't believe so get naked hose
yourself down get in the freezer with
the ice cream for 90 minutes didn't see
how well you do
but five years ago all the medical
doctors in the world got together at a
big international convention they wanted
to do a study and find out what it was
that drove certain patients to give up
money you know when something happened
and the doctor tried to settle out of
court
wave a $1,000,000 check in front of
people's face 1 million dollars tax-free
these people say no money doesn't matter
I'm gonna take this doctor before a jury
and show that he's a quack and a fraud
and a butcher and all those sort of you
want to know what it was it turned the
patient's button on to get him to do
that what they found out was this it's
always a patient who felt slighted when
they were in pain or in trouble and the
doctor then did something wrong and hurt
them and this doctor was one who is
notorious for coming in the examining
room you're laying there in your gown or
naked on the on the couch or the
examining table and kept looking at your
watch and looked at the record never
touched the patient or shook their hand
or talked to them directly in their eyes
but just looked at the record and say
okay I'm the right prescription ran out
the door calling to his nurse to get his
car up because he had a golf appointment
these are the ones that patients just
wanted to go after him and you shouldn't
be too surprised that this is the
approach that the medical profession has
taken to prevent those types of suits
this is from the Landsat the top British
Medical Journal the top international
medical journal and was two professors
of medical ethics from the medical
school at the University of Western
Ontario up in Canada and what they said
was this acting classes should be
required in medical schools so doctors
can learn just when to provide a
perfectly time compassionate look or a
touch on the hand and that was supposed
to avoid all these suits where patients
thought that doctors didn't like them so
if you go to a doctor for every little
thing you don't know if they're acting
or not they don't you don't even know if
they know if you're alive or dead you
don't know they're Gork down on
something or sober you don't know if
they're gonna give you one of those 70%
of the prescriptions that are gonna kill
you these are all reasons why you want
to avoid stepping on the landmines get
as much information as you can yourself
make as many of your own decisions as
you can save yourself unnecessary risk
that's concept number one concept number
two these are all the positive things
that most of you are here for tonight
these are the positive things that you
can do to direct yourself towards
reaching 120 140 and basically what you
want to do is give your body all of the
raw materials it requires to maintain or
repair itself most of us don't think in
those terms we require maintenance
materials just like any machine if you
will that tractor can you run a tractor
or a car without coolant and oil no you
wouldn't think of it and yet you know
the equivalent we try to do that for own
bodies so let's look at what we need to
maintain ourselves and repair ourself we
need 90 essential nutrients 60 that 6ol
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids
and the reason why these things are
called essential nutrients is twofold
number one our bodies cannot manufacture
them we must consume them every day
either in food or supplements and number
two if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for six months 12
months a year or two years
guess what happens you get on the
average ten deficiency diseases ten
deficiency diseases times 90 essential
nutrients that's nine hundred diseases
that are preventable with proper
supplementation and the nice part of
this story is if you've had any of these
deficiency diseases for five ten fifteen
twenty thirty years and you start
supplementing coz you just learn about
this you have every honest expectation
of getting significantly better maybe
even a hundred percent better so you
have everything
and nothing to lose by considering this
as we've learned tonight the media is
interested and what you're interested in
because it sells newspapers so to speak
they sell a lot of newspaper if they
have a nice story and everybody runs out
to get one if you hear a radio program
that everybody's interested in they sell
more advertisement so this is why you
hear a lot of health programs on radio
and on TV and you see at newspapers and
magazines and my personal favorite of
all the health articles was this one
here April 6 1992 a little over four
years ago it was the first time that the
subject of vitamins and minerals was
treated in a positive way by any
mainstream publication Time magazine no
less cover says the real power of
vitamins new research shows they may
help fight cancer heart disease and the
ravages of aging prior to this article
mainstream magazines would only say
things like well vitamins and minerals
are quackery and hoaxes and fraud
charlatanism nobody needs those things
you can get everything you need from
your four food groups now if you haven't
read that article again April 6 1992 I
had you to go to a library public
library school library to dig it out and
read it
there was six positive pages there was
only one negative sentence and as you
might guess it was offered by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article what do you think about
vitamins and minerals for human
nutrition here's what he said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do any good
sniffs dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote now a Missouri translation
of that is you're just peeing away your
money
myzel wat up your dollars and throw them
in the toilet and flush them away you
know you get everything you need from
your four food groups that little
sentence has killed more Americans than
all of the foreign enemies with their
rifles and artillery put together you
can get everything you need from your
four food group it is not true believe
me it's not true no and I can guarantee
you after having done those 17,500
autopsies and over four hundred and
fifty four species of animals plus three
thousand human beings for a comparison
having practiced for 12 years in
Portland Oregon as a general family
practitioner pushing 60 myself and
having kids this tall and grandkids this
big and not-too-distant future great
grandkids I'd rather pee out 50 cents or
a dollar day worth of excess bye
and minerals that's cheap insurance if
you don't invest 50 cents to $1 a day in
yourself as sure as God made little
green apples you're going to invest in
the lifestyle of a medical doctor
because when you pay them hard cash out
of your own pocket or indirectly through
insurance or indirectly through taxes
and Medicare not a single penny of that
goes to better understand manage treat
prevent or cure catastrophic diseases
and kids breast cancer and women
prostate cancer and Men diabetes heart
disease cataracts it pays the doctor's
mortgage pays of doctor's mortgage no
matter how you're struggling with your
bills that pays a doctor's mortgage and
when you pay the doctor after the second
week of the month you're paying as
Mercedes payment you pay the doctor
after the third week of the month you're
paying the tuition for their kids to go
to medical school at Harvard or worse
yet Yale Law School so easy there's a
bunch more Yale lawyers running around
we got a whole white house full up and
look what's going on in there
oh we could get into that I mean that's
why they call me the Rush Limbaugh of
alternative health okay now one of the
things that I used to do for my patients
was send them a two-cent photocopy a
little article they'd find in newspapers
and nutritional journals and medical and
veterinary journals things that they
could do themselves nutritionally or
with herbs or whatnot and got to be
quite a thing 250,000 people a month one
of these two sentences so I turned it
into a magazine that comes out every
couple of months but I'm going to show
you what I used to give my patients and
what you two can can get let's start out
with cancer the number two killer of
adults the United States if you take
nothing else home tonight but this piece
of information it was worth you're
coming this little study was done by the
National Cancer Institute and they went
to Henan Province China for five years
and they chose Henan Province China
because it has the highest rate of
cancer and cancer deaths in the whole
world
it took 29,000 apparently healthy people
ranging in age from 40 to 69 and they
divided them up into little groups and
gave each group a different vitamin
different minerals sometimes
combinations of vitamins and minerals
and after five years they untangled the
study and here's what they found if
you've got a single nutrient not much
positive happen when it came to reducing
the death rate from cancer and not too
surprising vitamin C didn't do much by
itself Linus Pauling took 10,000
milligrams of vitamin C every day for 35
years still died of cancer retinol or
vitamin A didn't work zinc riboflavin
the trace mineral molybdenum niacin none
of these things worked as single
nutrients but one group showed
significant benefit they took three
nutrients double the American RDA I mean
a pitifully low dose double the American
RDA 20 cents a day beta-carotene vitamin
E in the trace mineral selenium and they
showed a reduction in deaths from all
causes by 9%
this included suicide and pneumonia and
car wrecks and cancer and diabetes and
heart disease and aneurysms and whatnot
reduce deaths from all causes by 9% they
reduce all cancers regardless of the
type of cancer by 13% and the type of
cancer most prevalent in henan province
stomach and lower esophageal cancer
they're reduced by 21% saved almost
one out of four simply by taking in
three nutrients beta-carotene vitamin E
and selenium now don't wait for your
doctor or your government to give you
this information if they haven't already
yelled at you or sent you an urgent
health of RAM or had their nurse call
you they're not going to do it I mean
we're talking this was two and a half
years ago so that you need to just take
the bull by the horns and do it yourself
now my very favorite disease and I call
it my favorite disease being camp such a
thing as a favorite disease is our
thright Asst and the reason why I like
arthritis it very clearly shows people
what they can do for themselves and once
you get enough confidence in dealing
with a disease you say well gosh maybe I
can be this good and working with
another one and so on
and so it kind of gives you that
confidence you need to make some
decisions on your own without having to
ask a doctor for everything now there's
not a single medical treatment designed
to fix arthritis you have 75% of all
Americans over the age of 50 get it to
one kind or one degree or another and
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control over the next seven to
ten years 35 million baby boomers of
whom there's quite a few in this room
are going to get it
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to fix it by contrast in
veterinary medicine were encouraged to
find nutritional formulas that are
designed to to prevent and cure all
kinds of diseases and animals including
arthritis so the advantage my patients
had was I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician so I went into my veterinary
background and I took all these
veterinary formula is designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and in
chickens and turkeys and pheasants and
pigeons and dogs and cats and sheep and
pigs and horses and cows and lions and
tigers and bears and and adapted them to
human use and I came up with what I
called dr. Wallach Spig arthritis
formula not because there's any pigs in
there but because it was used to prevent
and cure arthritis and pigs now this
little formula over the last 20 plus
years I have literally seen regrow
cartilage and bone in literally tens of
thousands of people right now there's
over a quarter of a million people a
month using dr. Wallach spigots rhinos
formula and it's going up at a rate of
three to four thousand new people a
month and the reason is of course it
works
no the medical profession would differ
with this they say no Wallach that's
absolutely not true everybody knows you
can't regrow collagen bone when you have
bone
bone arthritis the only thing left for
you medically is to have joint
replacement surgery and I'd have to
agree with them I'd have to agree with
them that if the only role matures are
using is aspirin and Tylenol Gold shots
and methotrexate and prednisone
cortisone you're not gonna regrow
collagen bone because those are not the
raw material to do it they have many
many side effects many of which are
fatal one of these things
over-the-counter and prescription
medications don't work anymore to
relieve pain and inflammation the only
thing left for you medically is joint
replacement surgery and these procedures
are all directed towards relieving pain
I mean it's such a terrible painful
disease that people are willing to let
surgeons cut out their knees and their
hips and their shoulders in any attempt
to relieve pain so I came up with dr.
Wallach Spig arthritis formula
well Harvard Medical School's laid in
the bushes for me for 25 years and I
said ha we have finally found a way to
prove that well like as a quack and a
fraud and a charlatan because everybody
knows you can't regrow collagen bone and
they took what they thought was the most
ridiculous 1/3 of dr. Wallach Pig
arthritis formula and they gave it to 29
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over 15 to 20 years they took
him off all their medication wasn't
doing them any good anyway and the only
thing left for them medically it was
joint replacement surgery and they gave
him a heaping tablespoonful of ground-up
chicken college and orange juice every
morning for 90 days just three short
months and here's what happened after
ten days they had complete relief of
pain and inflammation something they
hadn't had in 15 to 20 years in 30 days
they can now open up a new pickle jar
that never had been open without pain of
the fingers wrists elbows and shoulder
in a 90 days just three months according
to Harvard Medical School not me 28 of
the 29 were clinically cured now you'd
think they'd call me up and say Wallach
we got to apologize to you hey next time
you come to Boston come on in we'll buy
you a lobster dinner you know because
gosh even the most ridiculous one third
of your Pig arthritis formula did some
good that's not what happened don't be
too surprised
here's what the medical director the guy
who's a professor of medicine
an avid medical school fast and here's
what he said quote after three months it
was clear that the drug was beneficial
unquote chicken college had become a
drug in ninety days now why would you
think that would happen but because you
can't patent chicken college so they
went out to the US Patent Office and
they got a used patent on chicken
college and you too now for thirty five
hundred bucks a month can get Harvard
Medical School's chicken carljan a
capsule arthritis cured thirty five
hundred bucks a month so if this sounds
a little pricey to you all you have to
do is go to Kentucky Fried Chicken buy a
$5 bucket of chicken throw away their
meat and eat the ends off the bones is
the same stuff now if you have several
people in your family that could get a
little pricey you know if they have
arthritis so what you want to do then is
go to the dumpster behind the KFC in the
dark of the night take your kids or your
grandkids give an empty five-gallon feed
bucket put them in that dumpster let
them scoop out the bones for you and
take them home put those bones on a
cookie sheet put them in an oven bake
them dry pound them into a flower with
your own ball-peen hammer and then fill
those chicken cars you know those
capsules yourself you know you just
don't wanna let anybody know what you're
doing because if the word gets out you
know Francine is making chicken college
cabbage curing everybody in the
neighborhood of arthritis the FDA is
gonna come arrest you in your house for
manufacturing a patented drug or worse
yet they'll send Janet to save you from
yourself and she'll burn your house down
[Music]
so if you want to avoid all these legal
entanglements and you don't want to get
all those gushy chicken bones all over
your house all you have to do is go to a
good grocery store and get yourself some
either knocks gelatin or Willamette
Valley gelatin unflavored unsweetened
it's the same stuff as the chondroitin
sulfate in there which is the basic
building block to rebuild cartilage and
bone bone matrix bone foundation if your
neck sounds like a bag full of gravel
you got low back problems loose teeth
and all those kinds of things I'm gonna
give dr. Wallach spear arthritis formula
trying I'll give you the full formula at
the end another one of my favorite
diseases alzheimers disease it's a
physician cause disease pretty powerful
statement it's a physician cause disease
we didn't have alzheimers disease 40
years ago was not in any medical
dictionary medical textbooks it was not
taught in any medical class it only
became a disease entity in 1979 today
according to Ralph Nader rivals cancer
and cost $300,000 per patient and it's
the number four killer of adults over
the age of 65 behind cardiovascular
disease cancer diabetes then comes
Alzheimer's disease now we eliminated
Alzheimer's disease from animals from 40
years ago
do you imagine a dairy farmer with 400
hundred head of cows out in the pasture
with Alzheimer's disease he's yelling at
a mule and rattling the feed bucket
trying to get him up to get milk the
cows are all out there scratching their
head saying why do we want to go to the
barn to get milked and if we did where
is the barn because he had kind of
so the farmer has to put fuel in the ATV
and ride out there and hurt him up in
the you know fuel cost goes up labor
cost goes up so they have to raise the
price of milk nobody's happy so we
eliminated alzheimers disease by
eliminating vegetable oil corn oil and
soil from the animals diet and putting
in large doses of vitamin E and selenium
well this is one of those 2-cent
photocopies you should have gotten from
your doctors three and a half years ago
almost four years ago now this is not
from the National Enquirer this is from
the University of California San Diego
School of Medicine a very reputable
research institution and they said
vitamin E can ease memory loss and
Alzheimer's patients I don't know how
many of you saw that little article and
I'm waiting to get a copy of it so I can
make another overhead just last week
from one of the English universities
they came out and said yeah people take
in 800 units of vitamin E every day the
odds of them getting a heart attack are
alzheimers disease almost zero
alzheimers disease is an American
disease it does not occur in third world
countries it does not occur in Europe
it's an American disease that's because
all our doctor I'll tell you in a minute
I'll prove it to you in a minute this a
physician cause disease how many of you
hurt whether you believe it or not that
vegetable oils are healthier for the
terrible saturated animal fat with you
believe it or not raise your hand if
you've heard it that's pretty good about
50% the other half of you are either
asleep lying or have Alzheimers because
I know you heard it now we learned 50
years ago in the animal industry that
the vegetable oils were bad for you
because we tried to get animals to gain
weight faster by giving them 20% and 40%
of the ration as Cornell or soil because
it has double the amount of calories as
does crack corn oils have nine calories
per gram and carbohydrate type calories
from either beet pulp or crack corn has
something like four and a half calories
per gram and sure enough for the first
couple of weeks that animals were on the
oils they gain weight many times faster
than ones just getting carbohydrate
calories but in six weeks they all died
of heart attack so we knew it was a good
idea that went bad somewhere and they
said well what do we do with this stuff
no farmers dumb enough to give it to his
livestock anymore look we've contracted
with farmers to grow millions of tons of
corn oil and soil every year for the
next 50 years what do we do with this
stuff he said well it's not proven in
human
yet that is dangerous let's convince
people that vegetable oil is good for
them and they've done a pretty good job
over the last 35 40 years happening all
you gotta do is go into the dairy case I
mean this is really blatant you go to
the dairy case and the grocery store you
v find 85 brands of corn oil margarine
in the dairy case that's how much
they've brainwashed people usually
gotten this information three and a half
years ago vegetable oils can cause heart
disease
it's a nightmare said dr. Edward emka
and a specialist in food oils for the US
Department of Agriculture it's really a
nasty thing when you try to explain it
there's now total confusion for
consumers why would it be total
confusion for consumers well that's
because the truth is different from what
you've been taught for 35 years here's
another look at the same problem
margarine can increase your risk of
heart attacks
a lot of people say to me well I've got
a whole freezer full of tub margarine
can I use that
top margin stick margin doesn't matter
it's the same thing this is what they
called the Harvard Nurses Health Study
and they took 90,000 nurses over 20
years divide them into two groups put
one group on margarine as their spread
for the crackers and bread and cooking
shortening put the other 45,000 nurses
on butter for their spread their
crackers and bread and cooking
shortening the end of the 20 years they
looked at their death certificates and
for every hundred nurses who had died of
a heart attack 70 of them were in the
margarine group you have a two and a
half times greater risk of dying of a
heart attack if you use margarine than
butter now the biggest fraud never
perpetuated against the American people
the biggest fraud ever perpetrated
against the American people
is this cholesterol thing this is one of
those 2-cent photocopies you should have
got from your doctors three and a half
years ago top researchers reluctantly
admit that low levels of cholesterol are
bad for you low levels of cholesterol
are worse for you than high levels of
cholesterol this is from the University
of California at San Francisco a
researcher who is renowned as the top
the top medical researcher on
cholesterol and cardiovascular disease
his name is Steven B Holley here's
another look at the same study three and
a half years ago here's what he said
quote what it comes down to is there's
an extraordinary set of observations
that have emerged this year because for
the first time we have a large enough
study to really see them what he said
there was for 40 years we've been giving
you caca
you know stuff is in baby diapers and we
didn't really know the truth about
cholesterol so he made stuff up just we
thought it was good for him so he made
stuff up but now after 20 years we
finally have the truth now why in this
God's green earth would anybody want to
have a blood cholesterol below 180
always because a doctor instructed you
or ordered you to do it now about seven
years ago actually was May first seven
years ago I began lecturing 300 nights
out of each year like this all across
the country and in the beginning the
crowds were just three people then it
was 20 and then 50 and then a hundred
and for the last five years has been
hundreds and the interest is growing and
people doing things for themselves and
my wife said look I'll support you on
the field if you want to do that for
seven to ten years but it's gonna you
know it's gonna take a lot of toll on
you eating hotel food and having weird
hours and driving all night to get one
place or another what I want you to do
if you're gonna do this is to have
yourself a hobby and every time you feel
yourself really getting so warped out
that they're gonna come after you with a
butterfly net or a straightjacket study
this hobby and get yourself calm down
before you get in front of an audience
say well that's good advice I'll do that
but after the hundreds of different
things I looked at I settled on
collecting obituaries of medical doctors
as my hobby now the reason was of course
it's a very useful piece of information
if doctors knew what they were talking
about when it came to health and
longevity if you separate them out from
the rest of the American population they
should be healthier and live longer than
anybody else and boy was I surprised
I started out a hundred years ago June
15th 1895 in JAMA which is the premier
medical journal in the world actually
generally American Medical Association
and they did a survey a hundred years
ago on deaths and American doctors what
they found out the average lifespan of
medical doctors a hundred years ago was
fifty four point six fifty four point
six the average population in America
the average lifespan was 62 now they
were in trouble then a hundred years
later January of 1993 I redid the study
using obituaries from the journal
American Medical Association just like
they did originally and guess what the
average lifespan for medical doctors
today is fifty seven point six I gave
him the benefit of the doubt and rounded
it up to 58 the average lifespan for the
average American is seventy five point
five he gained almost 20 years
statistically by not going to medical
school so I brought you a few my
favorites so you can see what fun I'm
having and of course all of these are
physicians who have died of nutritional
deficiency diseases Stuart Cartwright
aged 38 was family practitioner
good-looking kid I'm sure he could have
been a movie actor if he wanted to I
promise you he married the prom queen
and he probably had a Mercedes
convertible in Southern California
probably never repaid a student loan all
the things that medical students put on
their list of wishes and he dropped dead
in his home from a ruptured coronary
artery aneurysm and the fascinating
thing to me is this is something we
learned in turkeys in the 50s 1957 how
to prevent and in the early stages
reverse aneurysms and of course this was
from a study of 250,000 turkeys the USDA
put on a complete turkey pellet trying
to get these turkeys to finish for
market within a week or two of each
other as opposed to strung out all over
the whole summer when their own pasture
and in the first 13 weeks fully half of
125,000 of them died farmers were out
there every morning picking him up with
a bushel basket full took him into the
state diagnostic lab to see what they
died from when they cut him open at
autopsy every one of them had died of a
ruptured aortic aneurysm and one of the
clever pathologist says ah that's got to
be due to a copper deficiency because
everybody knows that the elastic fibers
and arteries and skin and other tissues
require a large amount of copper to be
manufactured and the mechanism of an
aneurysm is identical to the mechanism
of a balloon on the weakened wall of a
tire you know when you hit a chuckhole
and you break the cords in a tire the
internal pressure on the tire blows a
balloon and your thumb time a highway
and heat it up it'll blow same way with
an aneurysm when you get a breakdown of
those elastic fibers the internal
pressure and an artery even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon is called
an aneurysm and if it ruptures you bleed
to death
so they got excited about this they
doubled the amount of copper in those
pellets the next year they tried to
raise 500 thousand turkeys and they did
not lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm they went from a 50% loss to a
0% loss simply by adding a little copper
and they got all excited about this and
they started looking at copper deficient
diets and copper levels in human blood
and tissues and what they came up with
was this the very first symptom of
copper deficiency in human beings is
white gray or silver hair I see a lot of
copper deficiency in this room tonight
ok and of course you don't to be like a
medical doctor and just color your hair
because you know that's treating the
symptom but not obviously getting down
to the root cause of things if you don't
take action at this point and don't give
yourself some of the right type of
copper what's gonna happen is you start
getting a breakdown of the elastic
fibers in your skin and you get crow's
feet around the corners of your eyes and
your mouth parts of your Anatomy begin
to sag and you know you're in trouble I
mean you go to your doctor and he says
you know I've got a golf buddy down the
hall who is a plastic surgeon for
$10,000 he'll make you look 20 years
younger but you don't need a boobie lift
a tummy tuck or derriere lift or a
facial lift all you need is some
colloidal copper and everything will
come back up just like you have a
hydraulic jack under it
now if you don't take action at that
point you got to break down the elastic
fibers and large veins of your legs you
get varicose veins don't take action at
this point you get a breakdown of
elastic fibers and large veins of your
exhaust pipe and you get hemorrhoids so
if you if you have hemorrhoids varicose
veins things that sag wrinkles white
gray or silver hair the odds already
have aneurysms developing in you
somewhere and don't be like old Frank
who dies suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm
and all his friends get together Denny's
after the funeral and eating something
that famous blueberry cheesecake and
they say we never thought Frank could be
the first one to go I mean he was mr.
Fitness this guy walked five miles
before breakfast every morning he ripped
the chicken skin off the chicken before
he ate it took an aspirin every day he
went to the health club every night and
did those water aerobics with young
people and he always looked so
distinguished in his gray hair his body
been screaming at him for 25 years Frank
give me some copper Frank give me some
copper he just stood the mirror and said
man I look like Einstein you don't like
gray here what did Einstein died from a
ruptured aortic aneurysm what color was
Einstein's here
snow white this fellow here dr. Michael
PRTs 38 years old also 20 years before
the average for physicians and 40 years
before the average American he was a
jogger dr. Michael P artis was a jogger
38 years old and he encouraged his well
patients to jog with him he gave him a
ten percent discount on his services if
they would jog with him a minimum of 15
days out of each month so he had this
big groupie thing every day that all
these patients were jogging with him
because they wanted this ten percent
discount in the services well he
collapsed and died in front of his
horrified patients while they were
jogging of a simple cardiomyopathy heart
attack a selenium deficiency and because
they didn't want to give up that 10%
discount on the services they all kept
jogging nobody stopped to give him any
CPR
[Music]
dr. Martin Carter age 57 one year before
the average for physicians and 20 years
before the average American was an
expert according to the New York Times
obituaries this guy had every drop of
medical education you could get in the
whole world but he didn't have expensive
urine she didn't have expensive urine
even though his mom and dad were proud
of him the cause of death was a ruptured
aortic aneurysm just like those copper
deficient turkeys because my mother's
favorite obituaries she found it I have
to use it all time keep mom happy this
was what two almost three years ago now
July of 93 dr. Gayle Clarke aged 47 was
the chief cardiologist our hospital
she's walking down the halls of her
Hospital to his stethoscope around her
neck she drops dead let's say you're a
heart patient in the ICU and your
monitor shows you're stable
beep-beep-beep and then you hear him you
know they closed the curtain next to you
you don't know it's your doctor being
brought in there you hear him cut the
clothes off there he's yelling for the
code cards and the paddles and contact
gel and I need some bicarb and some
epinephrine and that sort of thing then
you hear and say okay clear everybody
here we go
contact didn't work okay we need some
turn the paddles up more gel more
contact y'all clear clear here we go
then they turn on the monitor
flatlines so you know she's dead we say
nurse now your monitor is going because
you're nervous hey nurse nurse wouldn't
on next door sound awful with all the
screaming and coke cards and dinner says
you know your cardiologist the chief
cardiologist of this hospital dr. Gail
Clark age 47 just croak next door from a
cardiomyopathy a heart attack a simple
selenium deficiency disease you see all
the patients holding their gowns and
they're running out of the hospital as
fast as they can go because whatever the
chief got they don't want I mean if it
kills the chief and you why would you
want it dr. George Koehler
the youngest person ever to win the
Nobel Prize in medicine he's in the 20th
century dr. George Koehler 37 years old
wins the Nobel Prize in medicine for his
work with antibodies monoclonal antibody
is going to save people from cancer
which is a righteous type of research
eleven years later age 48 boom drops
dead from a cardiomyopathy a heart
attack a simple selenium deficiency
disease because he believes you could
get everything you needed from your four
food groups remember I told you when I
came back from Africa I was supposed to
find an early warning system and it
turned out that the early warning system
is not a wombat or a koala bear at
ruby-throated hummingbird or a rare and
endangered fish or reptile turns out
that our early warning system is our own
young athletes according to the CDC the
Center for Disease Control 100,000 young
athletes under the age of 30 drop dead
each year during exercise or a game or
immediately after exercise or a game
100,000 double the number who are killed
in car accidents 10 years ago I began to
see articles like this in medical
journals sudden death and young athletes
and this is a small study but it gives
you a flavor what's going on here 29
highly conditioned competitive athletes
ages 13 to 30
dropped dead during a game in this study
35% of them died of ruptured aneurysms a
copper deficiency the other 65% died of
cardiac the heart disease a selenium
deficiency now what do you think is the
most dangerous sport in the world you
can yell him out to me boxing basketball
hockey
football jogging cross-country racing it
turns out that it is basketball 45% are
45,000 out of the hundred thousand are
basketball players and I'll show you why
in a minute
football happens to be second here's
some of the faces of the young Americans
these are you know the pride of America
these are kids who are healthy
apparently and just suddenly drop dead
during games 14 15 16 18 years old
here's a water polo player 14 years old
Carney Mopti heart-disease 15 years old
Stanley Hawkins
freshman in high school just practicing
basketball drops over dead from a
cardiomyopathy heart attack slim and
efficiency Deron millat 22 years old six
foot five had just signed a
multi-million dollar contract with an
NBA team just shooting some baskets and
it wasn't even a game he was in his
jeans t-shirt just shooting some baskets
went for a layup put the ball in the
basket came down he was dead
hurting him out with a heart attack slam
inefficiency here's one that's a little
more famous Reggie Lewis 27 year old
captain in the Boston Celtics April of
1993 a little over three years ago now
collapsed during a playoff game with the
Charlotte Hornets and was diagnosed very
accurately and very quickly as having
cardiomyopathy heart disease and because
he was a 65 million dollar contract
athlete the Celtics hired the top 12
cardiologist in the whole world and
referred to this collection of doctors
which they accumulated in Boston as the
dream team of cardiologists they called
him the dream team of cardiologists gave
him a million bucks he should refer all
their patients out to other doctors and
lo and behold lo and behold they were
supposed to devote their full time to
saving Reggie he didn't take fifty bucks
of their money and give it to a medical
student a pre-med student to go to the
medical library and like Star Trek as a
computer computer what are all the known
causes of cardiomyopathy if they would
have done that the computer has said
there's only one known cause of
cardiomyopathy it was discovered in
animals in 1957 and
disease was eliminated from animals in
1958 it was proven in human beings in
1972 of the double-blind crossover study
with 45,000 human subjects and the
disease was eliminated in the country in
which this was done the only known cause
of car team up with the heart disease in
both animals and human beings is a
deficiency of the trace mineral selenium
they didn't do that as a result they
didn't give Reggie Lewis ten cents a day
worth of selenium if they would have
done that Reggie Lewis would still be
alive today
and as a result while they were
bickering three months after his initial
heart attack Reggie Lewis 27 years old
July 28th 1993 dies of a second
cardiomyopathy heart attack now if the
dream team of cardiologists wouldn't
give a 65 million dollar athlete ten
cents a day worth of selenium what's the
chances of your cardiologist giving you
any watch my lips if you haven't gotten
it by now none I think you get the
picture now if you wait long enough if
you wait long enough justice has a way
of coming around doesn't it you know my
hobby so you shouldn't be too surprised
the year and a half after Reggie Lewis
died the chief for the dream team of
cardiologists won dr. W Thomas Nessa a
marathon runner finished the Boston
Marathon three times before he died
was the vice chairman of the department
of cardiology at habbit medical school
age 48 mom drops dead from a cornea
myopathy heart attack dr. w thomas ness
a member of the dream team of
cardiologists who treated the late
boston celtics captain Reggie Lewis died
in his own home of the same thing I mean
this guy had to be malignant dumb right
I mean he didn't learn anything from a
65 million dollar autopsy November 1995
Sergey Grinch off to time gold medal
winner of Paris Figure Skating 1988 1994
and the Olympic Games was just tynus
Cates was just tying a skates at Lake
Placid niar getting ready to get into
peak physical condition for his upcoming
Olympics drops over dead age 28 from
cardiomyopathy heart attack just like
Reggie Lewis age 27
here's one mantlet choppa backup pitcher
San Diego Padres 20 years old clamps and
died from Kearney mapa the heart attack
here's a good story Evander Holyfield
the Evander Holyfield was banned almost
three years ago now from boxing because
he developed cardiomyopathy heart
disease not the sudden type that kills
you instantly but slow wasting in the
heart muscle kind of a muscular
dystrophy of the heart muscle he was
banned from boxing because he couldn't
pass the physical anymore about seven
months into his retirement I ran into
one of his physicians at a seminar like
this in Atlanta we talked about the
relationship between selenium deficiency
and carni mapa the heart disease and he
began to give Evander Holyfield some
selenium ten months later his
electrocardiogram goes to normal and he
passes the physical the boxing
commission something that never happens
people with cardiomyopathy heart disease
never go back to normal but but then all
they get is pacemakers and heart
transplants so any rate he passes a
physical he boxes about a year ago wins
his first fight back in the ring three
months later he passes a physical again
loses the fight but then about I don't
know six eight weeks ago passes a
physical again four weeks ago he fought
again and won the fight and he's going
strong now simply because he took some
minerals here with selenium if you get
into this situation
don't let your doctor tell you only have
two choices either Kevorkian or the
heart transplant
you have a third choice and now you're
informed about this so you can make that
decision on your own the rate of brain
cancer in America has gone up 400
percent in the last 40 years and
everybody's pointing their fingers
towards cellular telephones and
everybody's trying to give me a cellular
telephone so I started examining this it
was there anything do that and you don't
have to worry about it if you use them
because 97% of people who use cellular
telephone or excuse me
97% of the people with brain cancer have
never even been in the same room with a
cellular telephone let alone use one so
you have to worry about that but there
is a little-known trace mineral known as
gallium this trace mineral gallium GA ll
I um when you give it to laboratory
animals and optimal amounts and they can
give them a chemical known to cause
brain cancer they don't get it if you
give them a laboratory experimental diet
as deficient in gallium and then give
them the same chemical they all get
brain cancer so I believe this huge
increase in rate of brain cancer in
America is a combination of a gallium
deficiency and a lot of chemicals in our
air water and food that do cause brain
cancer
think about all the performers who died
suddenly whose performances are almost
athletic in their presentation people
like Elvis he died of cardiac or they
blamed his death on the drugs but he
really died of cardamom deficiency
disease then you look at Conway Twitty
who died in front of 3000 fans in
Branson Missouri with a ruptured aortic
aneurysm a copper deficiency you look at
Michael Jackson collapsed in December of
1995 and was in the intensive care unit
for one week because his blood minerals
and electrolytes were all messed up
almost died when you go to a basketball
game a football game a track meet look
out there at those well trained athletes
the odds are all the couch potatoes in
the stands and bleachers have a much
better chance of living to be over 80
than those athletes do and here I'll put
out my challenge if you can find me an
obituary of any University semi-pro or
pro athlete who's lived to be over 100
I'll give you $100 bill
because I've looked real hard the
average lifespan for athletes both the
University and semi-pro and professional
is 62 to 65 depending on their sport
here's the final clue as many as 62
percent of the female college gymnast
suffer from anorexia they suffer from
anorexia 62 percent is that because it's
genetic no is that because all their
mothers hate them know that because they
think they're too fat absolutely not
I used to see a lot of these gals in the
70s and 80s when I practice up in
Portland Oregon because that was the
time of Olga Korbut and you may remember
her as being the darling of the world
because she won every gymnastic event in
the Olympics the same Olympiad with a
perfect score and everybody won their
little girl to be a Olga Korbut and I
used to see him
they get split lips and fractured and
dislocations because they you know they
were are weren't all perfect and they'd
hit those bars going full-speed and and
get dislocations and split lips and
twists and sprains and strains and
bruises but the ones that fascinated me
with a little eight ten twelve years old
that were depressed and anorexic
certainly not typical of a teenage girl
or preteen girl and so I used to do hair
analysis on them because that was the
only way I could communicate with them
because they weren't sociable they
wouldn't eat they didn't want to study
or they didn't want to do their
athletics anymore and sure enough every
one of them were severely deficient in
many many nutrients 3040 nutrients but
all of them were uniformly severely
deficient in - trace minerals zinc and
lithium zinc and lithium so I began to
give them as many as 25 or 30 nutrients
intravenously two or three times a week
paying special attention to giving them
lots of zinc and lithium and sure enough
in 14 to 21 days they were eating like
little pigs again they were real
interested in going out and training
they were sociable again and all the
parents who took their little girls who
were anorexic - counselors and shrinks
those older girls were counseled unto
death now you may remember Karen
Carpenter from the singing group the
brother-sister the carpenters she was at
30 years old give or take a year so she
developed anorexia because they had lots
of money they went around the world went
to all the shrinks and the counselors in
Moscow and Berlin
London and Paris all over the United
States and they counseled her unto death
because you cannot counsel somebody well
who has a terminal zinc deficiency you
have to give them some zinc now what
possibly could be the common denominator
between a 65-pound gymnast a
seven-foot-tall basketball player 250
pound box or heavyweight boxing champion
and these runners that have less than 4
percent body fat on them what could
possibly be the common denominator they
all sweat and when you sweat you sweat
out all 60 essential nutrients all 60
essential minerals you don't just sweat
out you don't just sweat out potassium
and Gatorade you sweat out all 60
essential minerals and when you sweat
out all of your selenium and don't
replace it by supplementation on the
average you're going to get a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you sweat
out all of your copper and don't replace
it by supplementation you're going to
get an aneurysm you sweat out all of
your chromium and vanadium you're going
to get diabetes you sweat out all of
your gallium and don't replace it you're
going to get a brain cancer if you're a
teenage girl and you sweat out all of
your zinc and your lithium you're going
to get anorexia get the picture now the
reason why athletes are early warning
system as a rule they sweat out more in
20 to 30 years in a couch potato dozen
80 years they've compressed a whole
lifetime of sweating into 20 years
that's why there were early warning
system now you don't have to be an
athlete to sweat though let's say you're
postmenopausal woman and you have night
sweats let's say you're a welder or a
farmer a carpenter let's say you work in
the oven room of a pizza hut any place
that you sweat even if you work in a an
office situation where you have an
air-conditioned office and you just use
a keyboard and as you never get one bead
of sweat on you I mean you can go a
whole week wear the same clothes
nobody'll know right but then you go out
every night and you do aerobics or you
jog and you sweat then so it doesn't
matter why you sweat whether it's for
recreation or at work if you don't
replace those minerals you're in line
you're putting yourself at high high
risk of developing a lot of these
degenerative diseases many of which are
debilitating and certainly many of which
are fatal what's the very first symptom
of mineral deficiencies and animals and
people
it's called pica and cribbing farmer
know about this when they see an animal
chewing on the hitching post and these
are a couple of Amish horses up in
Lancaster County Pennsylvania when they
see him chew chewing on the hitching
post defense rails things like shovel
handles the half doors on the bar and
the door jams on the barn a good farmer
recognizes this as an animal that's in
trouble though they are minerally
deficient how many of you either are
know of a chocoholic raise your hand
yeah that's the munchies that's Pike and
cribbing that's a mineral deficiency
it's the only thing will cause that how
many of you know of a Coquihalla car a
pepsi holic raise your hand yeah Oh a
day without 12 Pepsi as I can't function
okay these are mentally deficient people
and that's one of the reasons why we
have a weight challenge in America
because people have been taught to put
calories in their mouths instead of
minerals there's no calories and
minerals next time you have these
terrible cravings instead of putting
chips and dips and chocolate and donuts
in your mouth try some minerals you'll
not only lose weight but you'll feel
better and live longer
[Applause]
my favorite mineral is lithium the
reason why I like lithium is shrinks
think it's a drug that only they can
prescribe when in fact is one of those
60 essential minerals that everybody
needs every day and like all essential
nutrients if it's missing if it's
missing for six months nine months 12
months a year or so you get on the
average ten deficiency diseases which
include depression manic depression
bipolar disease suicidal behavior
violent behavior spouse abuse child
abuse domestic violence drug addictions
alcohol addictions these are all
symptoms of lithium deficiency and
people who've been challenged with sugar
natural or processed will talk more
about that in a minute I believe we
should be putting lithium in our
drinking water because first of all it's
safer than chlorine and fluorine and
number two we could eliminate 85% of all
domestic violence if we would just put
lithium in our drinking water now you
can pick up and diagnose a child with
lithium deficiency and one who's in
trouble by looking at their coloring
projects if you look at their coloring
projects if they're deficient lithium
and are sensitive to sugar we'll talk
about that in a second these are kids
who are going to take a dark color black
brown per
dark red dark blue dark green and
scribble all over the page with little
or no intent to stay in the line these
are kids who are in trouble
you can project these four five year
olds are going to drop out of high
school they're not gonna learn how to
write read or do math they're going to
have a lousy personal life they're never
going to be happy during a marriage
they're gonna be violent types and so
forth these are kids who are in trouble
they're gonna experiment with cigarettes
and alcohol and drugs but their
salvageable because this is the same kid
here six weeks later simply getting them
off of sugar natural and process no
ample juice no grape juice no honey no
molasses no Pepsi's no chocolate no
ding-dongs no supers sugar frosted
flakes and that sort of thing and
supplemented them this kid with lithium
chromium and vanadium look at the heels
in the boots and the boots the glove the
uniform sleeve the glove the border on
the foot and the border on the hat and
so forth all in the lines that tail and
so on and with more appropriate colors
you can save these kids if you just pay
attention it's not they don't just have
an art aptitude they're in trouble okay
now if these kids also wet the bed far
after they're supposed to be
potty-trained there's six eight ten
twelve fourteen years old may wet the
bed they have a history of scribbling
all over the page without staining the
lines they are cruel to little animals
and other kids and they love to play
with matches and fire these are kids who
if you don't save them at this early age
you can project they're gonna become
mass murderers and serial killers it
just happens that way here's what
happens next you start getting kids with
what's called geographic tongues
geographic tongues are red pulpy and
painful they have ulcers and erosions
all over their tongues these kids have
zero brain waves they can't learn how to
read write and do math if you don't take
care of them they're they're gonna drop
out of school and experiment with
cigarettes alcohol and drugs when they
hit 12 14 16 years old and look at the
allergic shiners under this kids eyes
this is not physical abuse he's just
sensitive to sugar and people are
sensitive to sugar just like some people
are sensitive to alcohol you know
there's a good alcoholic but a person
who will drink a beer and a shot of
whiskey they'll go to sleep
these are quote good alcoholics there's
people who drink a beer maybe have a
shot of whiskey and they get boisterous
and obnoxious and they start singing
loud songs and
loud and they think jokes are funny that
aren't funny and then you get people who
drink and they just get mean and become
downright dangerous to themselves and
everybody else the same thing is true as
sugar there are some people who take in
sugar and they get low blood sugar and
they just go to sleep some people who
get taken sugar they get rowdy and
attention deficit disorder ADHD
hyperactivity learning disabilities and
they get kind of obnoxious and then
there are people who take in sugar and
they become serial killers and they get
violent and so people are sensitive to
sugar just like they are to alcohol and
you get them off of sugar nancial and
process and supplement them with lithium
chromium and vanadium you can save them
and everybody around them here's a 20
year old you don't need to be a clinical
psychologist to see that he's depressed
look at the allergic shiners under his
eyes and these are the type of kids who
live on Pepsi's and ding-dongs their
whole life they're quiet they stay in
their rooms that were their headsets
they listen to their music or they might
play on the keyboards or their computers
and then one day when grandma gives them
an irritation of about a 0.1 on the
scale of one to ten you got to do the
dishes before I give you the car keys
they'll walk into the kitchen and pick
up the cleaver and smack grandma's head
off they'll respond with a ten right and
they're just irritated 0.1 now this is
all too common right now experts say the
30% of all American teenagers are going
to appear in juvenile court in nineteen
ninety-six one-third of all American
teenagers ayr8 is a terrible tragedy but
these things do go on all the time and
back I guess was the third weekend in
January of this year in 1996
there's up Moses Lake Washington on a
Monday night actually giving a seminar
like this and when he got to this point
guys in the front row said doc you don't
have to talk about teen violence in
Moses Lake I mean there's more people in
this National Guard Armory than there is
in the whole town and we only have a
couple hundred teenagers and they all
know each other by first name is kind of
like a big family and they didn't
believe they had any teen problems in
Moses Lake well that was Monday night
Friday at 2:00 in the afternoon an honor
student and junior high school walks in
with a deer rifle blows away the math
teacher and two of his fellow students
this kid was not on drugs he was not a
member of any gang there's no drugs and
gangs in Moses Lake Washington you know
the answer to why this happened
gonna bring it out of you what time of
the year is there more domestic violence
depression and suicide than any other
time of year Christmas holidays a week
before Christmas Christmas the time
between Christmas and New Year's from
New Year's until now Super Bowl day in
fact Super Bowl day has the largest
number of violent incidents than any
other day of the year Super Bowl day
what happens during these holidays that
happens more than any other time of year
sugar I heard people say as sugar you
get more cake more pie more candy more
cookies more punch more colas and drinks
of various kinds then you get any other
time of year it's not just on Sunday
afternoon I mean we're talking four
times a day in school after school in
the evening four times or ten times on
the weekend because it's party time
during the holidays and as a result the
people who are sensitive to sugar and
are going to get violent are depressed
come out during this time especially if
they're deficient in lithium chromium
and vanadium our attention deficit
disorder another one of those physician
caused diseases because the physicians
say sugar is okay it's better to have
ritalin than sugar you can have both you
know if you're good you can have sugar
and Ritalin mm-hmm
well if you take someone who has a DD or
ADHD attention deficit disorder attempt
and deficit hyperactivity disorder
regardless of age whether they're 2 or 6
or 8 or 15 or 25 or 40 and take them off
of all sugar natural and process and
supplement them with all 90 nutrients
paying special attention to make sure
that they get lithium chromium and
vanadium 98% I can't use the Cure word
but 98% will get 100% better
now the whole family has to do the same
thing you can't be guzzling cokes and
eating doughnuts and expect a six year
old or a 18 year old to give it up the
whole family has to change and eat the
same way for the benefit not only of
that child but for the whole family
because if something goes wrong the
whole family is in trouble
now this little gal here 300 years ago
would have been a vampire or a werewolf
your own villagers would have burned her
to death at the stake
maybe the village elders would have
killed her by driving a wooden stake
through her heart you may remember her
as Susan Smith the mother who drowned
her two sons from Union South Carolina
mm-hmm and we learned a lot about her
during her trial number one she tried to
commit suicide twice during high school
mm-hmm
hey lithium and chromium deficiency
nobody said to her Susan give up all
sugar national process we're gonna give
you some lithium chromium and vanadium
they didn't even give her any prozac all
they did was give her a hug and say
Susan everybody loves you and if you get
depressed again let everybody know and
we'll talk you out of this suicide thing
two years after graduating high school
she went further into her depression
they diagnosed her as being a manic
depressive and they put her on Prozac at
that time nobody took her off her sugar
and supplemented with any lithium
chromium and vanadium and two years
later when her boyfriend realized how
wacky she was at that time try to
disengage and break off from her and he
used the kids as a foil purposely
because most single mothers when put to
the test you have to give up your kids
if you want me to stay with you because
you know I'm not big enough to handle
these kids every time I look at those
kids I see another man I said you got to
give up those kids and most women would
say well you're out of here you bum I'm
not gonna give up my kids if you don't
take the package deal you don't get
anything but she didn't do that the
night before she drowned those two boys
she went from telephone to telephone pay
telephone to pay telephone in the
parking lot so the 7-elevens in Union
South Carolina and she tried to call
this guy because she figured out a way
to make everybody happy she remembered a
little incident that happened to her
when she was six years old and it goes
like this when she was six years old she
had six kittens and she wanted to keep
them all she loved them all but her
daddy said hey we can only afford to
take care of two so you got to give up
four and he took four of them out of her
arms and put him into a sack with a
brick and tie the sack and threw him
into a pond drown he said now that was
painless didn't hurt those kittens and
they're happy because they're in heaven
with God and God's happy because those
kittens are with him and you're happy
because you get to keep two instead of
none and I'm happy because I don't have
to feed six I only have to feed two and
she remembered that story and she said
well I can make everybody happy here
I'll just drown those two boys and it'll
be painless and they'll be happy because
he'll be in heaven with God and God will
be happy because they're in heaven with
them and I'll be happy because I get my
boyfriend and he'll be happy because he
gets me without the kids nobody took her
off of any sugar natural process or
supplemented her with any lithium
chromium
vanadium one more tragic story here and
then we'll get into the summary slides
and then we'll open up for questions see
if there's any health challenges you
want to talk about this kid here I could
have picked down from his coloring
projects when he was four years old
guaranteed we call him the Willy Wonka
serial killer
how many of you have ever seen the movie
Willy Wonka and the and the Chocolate
Factory raise your hand
yeah pretty fun little movie we call him
the Willy Wonka serial killer when he
was four years old he was caught on the
on the shoulder of a little state
highway in Indiana
h/h eating Road kills by hard taco
shells I mean we used to call these
things sale cats they were run over so
many times they're dry he's use them
like frisbees right talk about pica and
cribbing I mean he was eating Road kills
at age four when he was seven years old
he was thought to be part of a satanic
cult because he was twisting the heads
off his neighbor's chickens and nailing
him to the door jambs cutting the heads
off their dogs and cats putting them on
pikes and planting him in front of their
yard cruelty to little animals he wet
the bed until he was twelve years old
when he was 13 years old he was a
full-blown alcoholic he'd sit in class
and drink beer cans and crunch them and
disrupt the class but his teachers were
terrified to kick him out of class
because he threatened to burn their
house down he loved to play with fire
all right now because he was such a
threatening kid that gave him straight
A's and graduated him a year early on a
high school moved him right along he
then joined the army and became a medic
because he had such good grades they've
made him a medic and encouraged him to
apply to medical school the only reason
he did not get into medical school was
he was being treated as an alcoholic in
the army said hey you dry out I've
applied to medical school again we'll
take you well after three years the army
kicked him I was being a hopeless
alcoholic he moved up to Milwaukee he
lived with his grandmother and he worked
in a Chocolate Factory for four years
and ate chocolate for breakfast lunch
and supper because it was free two
employees used his minimum-wage paycheck
to buy alcohol and drugs at night and in
four years when that chocolate didn't
hold this horrible craving he had
anymore he killed this member Nate parts
of 17 human beings Jeffrey Dahmer
nobody's told him anywhere along his
life to give up sugar and supplement
with lithium chromium and vanadium him
all he did was say now Jeffrey is not
nice to kill this member and eat people
we require 90 essential nutrients 16
minerals 600 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and fortunately
for the thousands of years we've been
around we haven't had to think about
this too much as human beings because
our food plants our grains fruits
vegetables and us take carbon dioxide
from the air and manufacture long carbon
chains long carbon chains and many of
these long carbon chains are vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids and this is
where this myth came from you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups because plants do manufacture a
certain amount of vitamins amino acids
and fatty acids but we've tried this
experiment for a hundred years or 200
years and we've learned if you eat the
four food groups and don't supplement
you can live to be an average of seventy
five point five about half of what we're
genetically capable of so I sat down one
day and I said well how much of these
grains fruits and vegetables and nuts
you have to eat every day to live to be
over 100 and I calculate you need six
cups each of 15 different plant groups
grains fruits vegetables and nuts to get
enough vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids to live to be over 100 it has 90
cups a day it's a full bushel now you
have two problems if you want to do that
number one you have a capacity problem
if anybody in this room can eat a bushel
of anything I'll give you a $100 bill
number two if you eat a bushel of fruits
and vegetables every day guess where
you're going to spend most of your life
you guessed it you're gonna be on that
little house pot you know going through
about ten rolls of Charmin a day you'll
only be able to work with a laptop
computer and a cellular telephone you're
not gonna you're not gonna be able to go
anywhere else so even though it is
directly possible to get all the
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids you
need for meeting your four food groups
you can only expect to get seventy five
point five give or take sometimes 80
years sometimes 65 years but on the
average seventy five point five if you
want to live to be over 100 and be
helpful you have to take in supplements
of vitamins amino acids and fatty acids
now minerals are a different story
plants cannot manufacture minerals the
only minerals that you find in plants
are those are in the soil in which
they're grown plants will take up
minerals out of the soil and the reason
why we're in trouble in America is for
the last hundred years we've used a
simple fertilizer NPK nitrogen
phosphorus potassium we did on our farm
people still do today and they will for
the next thousand years use the simple
fertilizer NPK because it gives the
farmer the maximum yield in terms of
tons and bushels per acre farmers are
paid for tons and bushels nobody gives a
farmer any type of tax incentive or cash
incentive to make sure that you get all
sixty essential minerals that's your
responsibility farmers only generate
tons and bushels per acre that's what
they do and they do a very good job we
know that only takes five to ten years
to deplete the nutritional minerals out
of our farm soils and we've been using
NPK for a hundred years so you know you
don't have to be a rocket scientist to
figure out that there is a deficit there
US Senate document 264 says there's no
longer any nutritional minerals left in
our farm and rain soils and as a result
the crops that are grown there are
merely deficient as a result the animals
and people who eat these mineral
deficient crops get mineral deficiency
diseases and the only way to prevent and
cure them is with mineral
supplementation as US Senate document
264 now to me the scary thing about US
Senate document 264 is it was written
and published by the US Senate in 1936
60 years ago this information was known
60 years ago this is not yesterday's
news it's 60 years old this is the time
at which we began to put vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals into a No
feeds to make up the deficit
unfortunately unfortunately for human
beings we got wonder drugs at the same
time we got sulfa drugs in 1936 we got
penicillin in 38 cortisone in 42 and
everybody was led to believe it we give
medical research enough money and enough
time they'll find a wonder drug to fix
everything you just need to eat your
four food groups and run around
willy-nilly and everything will be all
right one of the studies that fascinated
me in Rio in 1992 at the earth summit
was this study here where they compared
the amount of minerals in our farm and
range cells compared to what was in
there a hundred years ago African farm
cells are 74% depleted Asian farm cells
are 76 percent depleted European farm
cells are 72 percent depleted South
America 76 percent the United States and
Canada North America is 85 percent
depleted
we're 10 to 15% worse off than anybody
else and of course the reason is we had
the Marshall Plan after the Second World
War for 40 years we fed the world more
tons and bushels they thought humanly
possible to grow per acre
now we put back in the saw was NPK NPK
and then there were 16 years of the
Russian wheat deals and I put back in
the saw was NPK NPK that's why our soils
are depleted now if I haven't gotten
your attention yet I want to show you
this map this is an overlay map of their
continental United States that black
areas have absolutely no selenium in it
and the dark grey areas is so irregular
that you wouldn't want to bet your life
on what may or may not be in there so if
you go to to a farmers market on the
weekend or you have your own garden
what's the chances of you having enough
selenium in your food to live to be a
hundred without supplementation zero
every farmer knows about this and they
put it in their animal feeds if you
think animals just need it and not
people okay let's look at two minerals
before we wind it up let's look at
calcium the number one mineral in the
body your body contains more calcium
than any other mineral 147 different
diseases if you're deficient in calcium
I'm just gonna go over the top ten with
you osteoporosis everybody knows about
that today it's the number ten killer of
adults over the age of 65 remember
seventy-five percent don't live 90 days
you get complications from those
fractures it's a horrible disease in
terms of human misery and dollar spent
thirty five thousand dollars to have a
hip replace
get them both replaces seventy thousand
dollars if that's uncomplicated if it's
complicated and have all kinds of
problems might be a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand dollars now as a
terrible disease as osteoporosis is and
human beings we don't have osteoporosis
and animals
that's because farmers have a lot of
common sense let's see a farmer out here
has a hundred head of cattle in his
pasture and no calves this year calls
the vet out he says hey doc I'm in
trouble I haven't had any calves this
year can't repay the operating loan I
lost a lot of money says do I get rid of
this herd and that'll come out and
examine the cow he says no the cows are
all ok but that bull up in that shed up
there has osteoporosis of both hips had
so much pain couldn't breathe the cows
that's why I don't have any calves he
says as a result as a result said what I
want you to do is give me $70,000 I give
that bull two new hips and next year
you'll have some calves now a farmer
being very practical you say now stand
over here doc and he whips out his deer
rifle and boom blows away the bull and
while the kids are cutting the bull up
into hamburger and roasts and steaks the
farm is in a dock for $70,000 I get a
new bull every year for 70 years only
gonna spend that kind of money in that
old bull but every once in a while we
get one we'd like to keep because he
throws good camps can we prevent this
osteoporosis thing and if it'll say well
sure I'm gonna prevent it all you got to
do is take ten cents every day in the
pellets worth of calcium ten cents worth
of calcium every day in the pellets of
those calves when you wean them off the
cow and you won't get osteoporosis in
the farmers doesn't wait a minute we can
prevent a seventy thousand to a hundred
thousand dollar vet bill simply with ten
cents a day worth of calcium he says yep
Fuhrman says well since I don't have
BlueCross BlueShield major medical
hospitalization Medicare Medicaid or
hillary to watch out for those calves
i got to pay for this out of my own
pocket because i'm gonna do the ten cent
a day calcium thing that's why we don't
have osteoporosis and animals receding
gums dentist and dental hygienist will
tie to floss and brush after every meal
if you believe that receding gums can be
prevented or cured by flossing and
brushing I have some oceanfront property
in Idaho I'd like to sell you
easy sell now as a veterinarian I've
literally seen hundreds of thousands of
animals rats mice rabbits dogs cats
sheep pigs horses cows lions and tigers
and bears and they don't flossin they
don't get receding gums
now they do get funky breath because
they don't floss but they don't get
receding gums now the reason why we
don't get receding gums and animals is
because we've dealt with the
osteoporosis thing if you have receding
gums regardless of your age whether
you're 12 15 20 25 30 40 50 60 70 80
doesn't matter if you have receding gums
lose teeth gingivitis pyuria
periodontitis bridges are plates you
have osteoporosis of a face or jaw bones
you see this 20 to 50 years before you
can recognize osteoporosis and the large
bones of your arms legs hips pelvis and
vertebrae so if you have any of these
problems you have osteoporosis of the
face and jaw bones arthritis 85% of all
arthritis is wear and tear arthritis 85%
of all arthritis is wear and tear
arthritis osteoarthritis degenerative
arthritis ankylosing spondylitis and of
course this is the type of arthritis
that can be prevented and you might get
100% better if you use dr. Wallach
speaker arthritis formula which is made
up out of a liquid multiple made up out
of a liquid multiple plant-derived
that has 72 colloidal minerals in it
will talk about colloidal minerals in
just a second and a liquid multiple and
the gelatin we talked about either Knox
or Willamette Valley gelatin either a
half ounce are the the 12 capsules and
five ounces of the calcium enriched
minute made ours use all that together
makes up dr. Wallach speaker arthritis
formula and taken faithfully twice a day
we have every honest expectation of
getting significantly better or maybe
even a hundred percent better even if
your neck sounds like a bag full of
gravel your joint sound like you have
rice krispies in there you know snap
crackle and pop you can't get about a
chair yourself you have excruciating
pain and so on you want to give it a try
if you have wear-and-tear arthritis
hypertension again we've already talked
about this
hypertension has nothing to do with salt
intake salt restrictions not going to
or fix it hypertension high blood
pressures actually do 85% of all
hypertension is due to a calcium
deficiency take in three times the RDA
recommended daily allowance by your
government and according to the inner
salt study and the study from Toronto
Medical School the calcium will resolve
your high blood pressure insomnia as you
roll around all night wake up in the
morning more tired when you went to bed
contrary to popular belief by physicians
it's not due to a barbiturate deficiency
earnings are a halcyon deficiency as due
to a calcium deficiency kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits the medical profession has the
malignant dumb belief that these things
are due to too much councilman your diet
and the first advice they give you and
you have any of these problems give up
all dairy and for God's sake don't take
any supplements with calcium in it when
in fact when you get kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
you have raging osteoporosis it's your
own calcium being moved around you need
more calcium or magnesium not less I
want you to be honest with me how many
have you ever had a foot cramp toe cramp
leg cramp eyelid twitch or anything like
that in your life raise your hand yeah
that's the first symptom of a calcium
deficiency if you're honest you'll fess
up to that and myself when I was a kid
when I was a teenager my eyelids used to
twitch so violently you could hear them
click I need to look into the mirror and
say do people see that is that my
imagination and one day I got the
twitching and the clicking together and
I called my mom and she came in and she
didn't know what it was so she panicked
we jumped in the car we drove 80 miles
to st. Louis and I ran into my first
female doctor when I was 14 years old
now remember she's an eye doctor her
name was Mary Jane Skeffington Mary Jane
Skeffington the eye doctor for some
reason 14 years old she had me stripped
down to my jockey underwear
now back then I was just a dumb redneck
kid from the pharma I didn't know any
better whatever she said I did now today
if a high doctor were to do that you
could go on Geraldo or Oprah and say you
were sexually harassed by your eye
doctor right but any rate she kept
looking in my eye with his hot thalma
scope for an hour and then go see
another patient she'd look into my eye
without Alma scope see another patient
he went on and on and on for two hours
and finally said doc you know listen I
played junior varsity football I'm the
captain of the wrestling team I actually
I'm on the weightlifting team and if you
have to amputate my eyelids go for it I
can handle whatever you need to do so
she goes into her office she comes back
she has a little Maybelline mascara
eyelash brush and a little mirror in my
little plastic boxes and I said what's
that fart
she says well the structure of your eyes
seems to be okay but you have these real
long eyelashes they've grown forward hit
your eyeglasses they've curl betting or
tickling your eyeball and that's what's
causing your eyelids to twitch I said
you're kidding me she says no that
appears to be what it is and I said well
well what do we do about and she says
well what I want you to do is every hour
I want you to alternate eyes take 15
minutes in each hour and work and
retrain those eyelashes and she starts
demonstrating to me she do it like this
I said no wait a minute
let's get this straight remember to sit
on the football bench with 25 guys
weighing over 200 pounds this is in 1950
right and you want me to sit there with
a Maybelline mascara eyelash brush and
play with my eyelashes and not only as
my team have cleats on their feet
there's these guys across the field 25
guys over tuna pound I said you got to
be crazy so I put on my pants I said she
doesn't know anything about football
right so I I went marching to the school
library and I found a health book out of
desperation it was written by two nurses
and I looked in the index and it said
muscle cramps muscle twitches I looked
in the book or it said to look and sure
enough it said this is all due to a
calcium deficiency and I said I ain't
know how to solve this problem I know
where we have some calcium it's in the
calf pellets in the barn so I ran to the
barn I started filling all my pockets of
my pants and my shirt and my jacket with
calf pellets and the next day at school
everybody else is eating M&Ms and jelly
beans old Wallach is eating calf pellets
because the alternative was the
Maybelline mascara eyelash treatment so
I was motivated now in four to five days
all those cramps and twitches went away
all those cramps and twitches went to
waste when I was 14 years old I knew
that doctors didn't know anything about
nutrition and that eye doctors perhaps
should go back to school and learn some
anatomy because they didn't know where
the eyes were
PMS premenstrual syndrome the University
of California San Diego came out six
years ago and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff a PMS can
be relieved prevented and cured they're
using the Cure word not me by tripling
your intake of calcium over and above
the RDA now low back pain that's a
pretty common thing low back pain how
many you either yourself or have known
somebody that had a disc surgery for
back pain and still had pain or more
pain after the surgery raise your hand
isn't that amazing almost forty fifty
percent of the people in the room now
Harvard Medical School was getting the
same feedback and they said there's
something wrong with this picture we're
doing these heroic disc surgeries to
relieve pain and 50% of people are still
having pain so they looked at it and
they said okay here's what we're gonna
do they took 1,700 people who had no
history of back problems never never had
a back problem and they were in the
teaching hospital Harvard for our sake
cataract operations 1,700 of them they
did camp scams on their back 85% of
those 1,700 people had bulging
degenerative and ruptured discs in
Harvard Medical School eight months ago
came out and said if anybody gets a disc
operation for back pain its medical
fraud because disk problems do not cause
back pain this problems can cause
tingling numbness and paralysis but not
back pain when you have low back pain
you have cramps and spasms and large
muscles of your back you can have
subluxation Zoar mail alignments of the
vertebra you have bone spurs calcium
deposits arthritis osteoporosis but not
disk problems if you have any of these
top ten problems or try a wall express
write us formula before you you know
elect to have any surgery don't be like
the average American who spends between
25,000 and 250 thousand dollars and
undergoes five to ten surgical
procedures for nothing more than the top
ten calcium deficiency diseases in
America it's really a terrifying thing
that people can be talked into that okay
last disease one more slide after this
diabetes the number 3 killer of adults
the United States causes blindness of
all kinds kidney failure kidney dialysis
kidney transplant contributes to the
numbers of cardiovascular disease the
number one killer of animals in United
States amputations at toes feet and legs
for ulcers that won't heal and gangrene
and most times you really don't have to
get an amputation to resolve those
problems but if you insist on getting
something amputated please please put a
tag on it so they get the right one you
know if you guys go in for an inguinal
surgery operation you want to get it do
not remove sign and put it in the
appropriate place that happens ok now
when your doctor diagnoses a new
diabetic patient his office he excused
himself goes into his private office
drops to his knees and gives thanks to
the Lord then he jumps up and he calls
his real-estate agent because he knows
over twenty thirty forty years you're
gonna go through all these problems if
he followed the standard treatment or
management of diabetes in human medicine
and as a result over twenty thirty forty
years you're worth to him two hundred
fifty thousand five hundred thousand
dollars is like adding another cow to
the Dairy Herd they know exactly how
much you're worth to them as a diabetic
and if you don't think that's true next
time you visit a doctor asked to see his
medical business office journals you
know they have business journals for
doctors and see what they say about
diabetic patients and heart patients and
cancer patients and how much on the
average that's why people pick certain
specialties because there's big bucks in
that area now to me this is criminal
because in 1957 we learned that we could
prevent and cure adult onset diabeetus
and animals by supplementing with -
trace minerals chromium and vanadium
chromium and vanadium and 11 years ago
1985 the medical school up at British
Columbia Vancouver Canada came out and
said that the trace mineral vanadium
alone could replace insulin for adults
on set diabetics so again make up 85% of
the diabetic population science that dog
food contains 40 minerals in the
complete analysis always contains
lithium chromium vanadium and selenium
ralston purina laboratory rat pellets
always contains a minimum
twenty-eight minerals and they always
contain lithium chromium vanadium and
selenium and I'll give anybody in this
audience a crisp new hundred dollar bill
if you can find any human infant formula
it contains more than twelve minerals
none of them contain lithium chromium
vanadium and only one pro soy be the one
has 12 has selenium in it none of the
rest do they have eleven ten nine or
eight minerals that's why they call
Similac Similac because it lacks
everything now if I've convinced you
that minerals and nutrition are
important to preventing disease and
adding health and longevity to your life
you have to be responsible for this
because your doctor doesn't get 30
seconds worth of clinical nutrition in
their medical school as a result this is
a blind spot for them and something they
never consider when a person comes in
with a health challenge they never
consider this aspect of the disease now
you have to know three things about
minerals number one there's three types
of mineral supplements there's the
original going back since time
immemorial since the beginning of time
there's elemental or metallic minerals
these are things like limestone oyster
shell egg shell sea bed minerals coral
calcium things like Oh clays of various
types
tums is a modern version of it eight to
twelve percent availability to animals
and people were not designed to consume
ground of rocks if you will to get our
minerals have you ever wondered why
people dread being 50 years old why the
whole population in the world suddenly
falls apart when they hit 50 you know
the teeth get loose the hair goes
whatever you got left is gray low back
problems high blood pressure sugar in
your urine interest in sex goes away
everybody dreads the big five oh right
well the reason is our ability to absorb
these elemental types of mineral
precipitously drops to 3 to 5 percent
about three years ago a guy in Grand
Rapids Michigan jumps up in the back of
the room says hey doc now I know what I
seen my porta potty business I said what
do you see in your porta potti business
he's well when we clean those things out
and disinfect them so we can use them
again we find hundreds and hundreds of
vitamin pills that come through people
to come on now how do you know their
vitamin pills well that's easy
they say thier gram em one a day centrum
and Centrum silver right on the coating
so next time you're on the pot and you
hear a plop plop clink clink it's not
poker chips coming through there
it's them pills are there any
chiropractors in the audience tonight
any chiropractors any chiropractors
raise your hands I can see against any
huh
okay well the reason why I ask that is
because chiropractors take spinal x-rays
when a chiropractor takes a spinal x-ray
guess what he sees he sees all these
pills lined up and her person tends to
be constipated those pills line up like
little boxcar is waiting to come out a
lot of people say to me doc listen you
know are you kind of fibbing to us a
little bit here pulling our leg I mean
I've taken 2,000 milligrams of calcium
every day for twenty years
I take a thousand milligram two of those
thousand milligram tablets every day for
twenty years and I still have insomnia
foot cramps toe cramps high blood
pressure bone spurs heel spurs arthritis
loose teeth my neck sounds like a bag
full of gravel and I said what kind you
take he'll say calcium carbonate calcium
gluconate calcium lactate and that's the
problem because out of a thousand
milligrams calcium lactate tablet eighty
six percent or eight hundred and sixty
milligrams is lactose or milk sugar only
14 percent 140 milligrams is elemental
or metallic calcium and let's not use
these complicated numbers up here for
absorption and usability let's take ten
percent of the 140 milligrams it's a
honest number and also it's easy math
ten percent of 140 milligrams is 14
milligrams so if you take two of those
thousand milligram tablets a day of
calcium lactate or calcium carbonate or
calcium gluconate you're not getting
2,000 milligrams of calcium we're
getting 2 times 14 are 28 milligrams to
get enough to get enough calcium to get
2,000 milligrams of usable calcium from
a calcium lactate thousand milligram
tablet you have to take 30 of those with
each meal if take 90 a day that's almost
a full 100 tablet bottle and the
cheapest the five you know five bucks a
bottle it's a hundred and fifty bucks a
month just for calcium you had 59 more
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids to
go so this is not a an efficient way
financially to take in minerals because
you've got all these other nutrients to
deal with plus you got the plop-plop
ding-ding
you know and additionally you're gonna
develop another physician cause disease
if they tell you to take this type of
calcium
you're gonna develop what I call BNF
disease BNF disease stands for belching
and farting if you take into 90 capsules
of anything a day you're going to
develop BNF disease you're gonna sound
like an elephant out in the woods with a
horrible belly problem
and you know you got it when your spouse
has to throw a canary in the bathroom to
see if it's safe to go in there now
during the 60s the animal industry came
up with chelated minerals because no
farmer is dumb enough to put a dollar in
an animal's mouth and have 99 cents come
out in the manure so we learned by
adding amino acids and proteins and
enzymes which are proteins to do work to
the elemental mineral it increases the
absorbability from three to five percent
to 40 percent and everybody got excited
about this during the sixties and today
because of this research you'll see a
mixture of elemental minerals and
chelated minerals in a good multivitamin
mineral supplement you know tablet but
the way that animals and people are
designed to consume and absorb minerals
is in the colloidal form colloidal
minerals are 98 percent available to
animals and people two and a half times
more available than the chelated
minerals ten times more available than
elemental or metallic they're liquid and
form by definition they cannot be
powders and capsules and pills and
tablets they must be liquid small
particle size there's seven thousand
times smaller than a red blood cell and
they're negatively charged as one of the
unique things about a colloidal mineral
is they are all negatively charged and
as you know like charges repel so
between being a small particle and they
repel each other they stay in suspension
forever as long as you don't let the
water evaporate now the way it's
supposed to be is that animals and human
beings are supposed to eat plants and
the plants are supposed to take the
elemental minerals out of the soil
convert them to colloidal minerals their
own used for their own metabolism and
biochemistry we eat the plants and
that's how animals and people are
designed to consume and absorb minerals
in the plant form colloidal minerals we
are not designed to eat ground of rocks
unfortunately US Senate document 264
1936 says there's no more minerals left
in our farm and rain soils unfortunately
in 1992 the Earth Summit in Rio says
there's no more minerals left in our
farm and rain so and plants cannot
manufacture minerals if there's no
minerals in the soil they cannot make
they cannot convert these metals to
colloidal minerals and they cannot
manufacture minerals now what about
these long-lived cultures that were
written up
in the National Geographic in January of
1973 what was special about them as a
genetic no they're all different races
are all different religions different
cultures
the Tibetans from certain mountain
tribes up there in the Himalayas and the
honza's in the eastern Pakistan the
Karakoram mountains the Russian
Georgians Azerbaijanis Abkhazians and
the Turkish Tani's in the Caucasus
Mountains in western Russia and the
vilcabamba Indians from the Andes of
Ecuador and my favorites I just like the
name of Titicaca and the Andes of Peru
what could possibly be a common
denominator between all these peoples
well there are two number one even
though they're different religions and
different races they were all persecuted
people they're all victims being chased
by the Kings men or bandits or whatever
and they chose to live and what would be
called the Badlands of their country I
mean horrible nothing no soil nothing
but rock mm-hmm and just how did the
throw the dice nothing that they thought
about they pick places to live in that
had 6272 minerals in the parent Rock of
the mountains they chose to live in
number two they chose places that had
less than two inches of precipitation
here no rain no snow to speak of so they
had to pick places that had a permanent
water supply and every one of these
cultures picked places that were within
50 to 100 miles of glaciers and they all
built aqueducts to carry water from
glaciers to their place where they lived
and worked and farmed now the water that
comes out from underneath of glaciers is
not clear like tap water Perrier
Evian or glacier water or geyser water
or Calistoga water is called glacial
milk because the water that comes out
from underneath the glaciers has so much
rock dust or rock flour suspended in it
that it's called glacial milk it looks
like whole milk kind of a bluish white
bluish grey as opposed to clear and if
you boil away a quart of glacial milk
you get two inches of minerals in the
bottom of that quart jug by contrast
boil away a quart of Evian or Perrier
water of twenty bucks a gallon and then
we're talking price here compared to
gasoline would you ever have thought
that water would be more expensive than
gasoline kind of interesting isn't it
now you boil away a quart of Evian or
Perrier water you'll get as much mineral
as you get on the head of a pen a big
contrast now not only did these people
drink this high
mineralized water and get eighty 12
percent and three to five percent after
age fifty because his metallic minerals
is ground up rocks as these glaciers
move up and down the mountains more
important than drinking it
they irrigated with it week after week
month after month year after year
generation after generation for 2500 to
5000 years they irrigated with this
glacial milk they replace literally
thousands of tons of these minerals back
into the soil every year through this
irrigation with his glacial milk and all
their plants are rich with these
colloidal minerals that are as a result
and all we do is put in NPK NPK NPK and
takes five to ten years to deplete these
nutritional minerals from our soil as a
result last year we paid 1.2 trillion
dollars with a T 1.2 trillion dollars
for health care these people don't get
diabetes they don't get heart disease
osteoporosis arthritis cancer they don't
get glaucoma they don't get cataracts
they don't have birth defects they don't
have jails full of violent criminals and
drug addicts they don't have a single
hospital they don't have BlueCross
BlueShield major of metal
hospitalization they don't have a single
doctor and they don't have these
diseases and they live to be over 120
240 now can you live to be over 120 140
without colloidal minerals no can you
get all these colloidal minerals out of
our food supply in the United States no
well can you keep all the things that we
love about the United States because if
I were to pay your way to go there and
live and guarantee you'd live to be over
100 you wouldn't do it because they
don't have Kenmore kitchens they don't
have electricity they don't have central
heat central air they don't have Rose
you don't have cars you don't have
televisions they don't have television
channel change I mean how can you be a
couch potato without a television
channel changer so can you have all
these things we love about America you
know including health insurance and and
still get colloidal minerals and the
answers of course yes these colloidal
minerals are available to you they've
been around since 1926 and of course
their plant derive they actually come
from an ancient prehistoric plant
deposit about 1926 or is this this
prospector who's an abysmal failure in
southeastern Utah who noticed when he
even though he couldn't find gold or
silver but he did notice when he drank
this funky tasting water in the stream
the only water source available to him
after a couple of weeks as our thright
us went away and he backtracked this
stream and he found that it originated
in a prehistoric Valley that had a
forest in it and when these trees and
brush and grasses took up all the
elemental minerals from the soil
converted them to colloidal minerals for
their own use
there was a cataclysmic event that
forest was entombed that valley in that
forest was entombed by a volcanic
eruption a very thin layer of mud ash
and lava not heavy enough to compress
this stuff into coal or oil
it was very arid in there not enough
moisture to fossilize or petrify this
plant material so today if you look at
it it just looks like real dark
chocolate coffee grounds you squeeze it
between your fingers you squeeze it
between your fingers it is the same
consistency as a chocolate chip you
might put in an oatmeal cookie its kind
of waxy that's because it's not rock
it's ground a plant material we grind
this stuff up into a flour we soak it in
a filtered spring water for four to six
weeks and we leach those colloidal
minerals out of those plants were taken
up in the prehistoric days things that
you can't get out of your soil and your
food anymore today
and of course has been around since 1926
we have liquid multiples that have been
around Oh 10 years and one year and so
forth and these are all available to you
all so I want to thank you all very much
god bless each and every one of them god
America it shocks most people when they
learn that we need 90 essential
nutrients we need 60 minutes 16 vitamins
12 essential amino acids and 3 essential
fatty acids it's even a bigger shock to
most people when they learn that man's
best friend the dog there's 40 minerals
in his food
our laboratory rats get 28 minerals or
less on his food and a human infant
their farming Li gets 12 Earl and our
dogs get Sparty minerals our rats get 28
their own kids are well below its really
a dog's life
it's these minerals it's a secret lasers
grind up these rocks comes out in the
form of glacial milk and these people
have irrigated with this glacial milk
season after season year after year
generation after generation - 2500 to
5000 years depending on the culture the
secret lies and the minerals that come
from these glaciers in these mountains
US Senate document 264 says that our
farm and rain soils are depleted in
minerals and as a result these crops are
deficient in minerals and as a result of
that animals and people who eat on these
crops get mineral deficiency diseases
when one considers the budget that the
American family puts into their food
each month and the fact that US Senate
document 264 says we no longer any
nutrients left in our farm soils and
therefore in our foods is not outrageous
to think of making sure that through a
couple of dollars a day you get all 90
essential nutrients it's kind of like
the modern version of an apple a day
keeps the doctor away if you really want
to find out what health is like don't
wait for the government don't wait for
insurance don't wait for Medicare and
Medicaid to do it they're not going to
do it for you they can't do it for you
even if they wanted to take them full of
your own health do it today don't wait
[Music]
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you for more presentations
and books that go into greater detail go
to doc Wallach Mediacom and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the FDA these products are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease the opinions
expressed in this informational program
are the express opinions of Joel D
Wallach BSD VM and D are not a
replacement for proper medical advice
and treatment in all cases we recommend
you contact your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions